[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
non
m
il
[Musique]
et
non
[Musique]
et
ah ah
[Musique]
on
moi
[Musique]
nous
je
[Musique]
il
et
[Musique]
je
salut tout le monde et bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle journée de la nations cup
salut mathieu bonjour québec le moulin
tout le monde alors mathieu thé chaud
quoi c'est ton premier jour de
commentaires sur cette compétition mais
tu la regardes est un peu de côté
quelles sont tes impressions
bah c'est intéressant et surtout en
cette peur de confinement et j'arrive au
bon moment parce qu'on va avoir fermé
sans doute le match le plus important
depuis le début de la semaine
alors on a le match de la compétition la
matière mais bon après j'avoue que
j'aimerais bien être aussi aux
commentaires demain ces deux mois c'est
sûr que ça sera intéressant mais il y
aura plus l'europe ils meurent là mais
bon on est citoyen du monde mais bon on
est pour maxime tantôt parce qu'il est
français mais non on supporte tout est
un peu plus l'europe mais bon dans
l'absolu on est surtout pour que ça joue
bien pour qui l'enjeu pour ce soit sympa
on est d'accord et franchement on a été
assez gâté j'étais un peu inquiet avant
le début de l'événement sur sur le
contenu et sur le niveau de jeu et j'ai
été rassurée parce qu'on a eu de belles
parties notamment les bonnes aronian qui
a fait plaisir à voir
assoa il ya deux jours avant-hier
superbe et il a fait une petite blague
après je te vois tu passes ta vu une
petite interview d'après elle qui était
assez marrante rudin ouf
il a chambré ace sur sa coiffure ah oui
je sais la scsc la chambre et robert s
du coup et dans la compétition est ce
qu'il ya un joueur quitte à
impressionner au tas de ça parce qu'il
ya quelqu'un quitte à un an dont when we
faire mon tournoi un an de quasiment ong
avancé qu il dit il n'y joue bien tout
le temps est bon la victoire qu'on n'est
pas les calebasses impressionnante et le
mec qui sort il sort des prêts pattes
ouais bah ils jouent pour le il joue
pour le pays je vous prends là il a
envie d'en lire les radios il a en
confinement il doit bosser les échecs
c'est un féru d'amérique espacité à dix
mille îles et en allemagne
je prends ça je ne savais pas il n'est
pas parce que j'ai compris les blocs en
allemagne donc il est même pas et que sa
famille ce qui est pas terrible mais on
a eu mal ça déconfit
commence à des comptines et mes bons
vins de ce qu'on appelle quand j'ai
entendu parler aux informations
illicites et c'était sarrio gamme live
ça rigolait pas population ya plus d'un
milliard d'habitants non non on va
peut-être me corriger n'hésitez pas 25
euros l'amant de subsides métis mme way
c'était je crois qu'ils sont plus variés
tout c'était c'était du sérieux donc
donc l'équipe d'un de l'équipe dengue
qui aurait pu faire beaucoup mieux en
réalité ils ont laissé échapper quelques
matches notamment le premier contre
l'europe qui tenait en main et s'ils
nous avaient battus ils seraient encore
aux peut-être au coude à coude pour pour
une qualification dommage pour eux ils
avaient peut-être l'équipe pour faire
quelque chose et puis ça s'est mal passé
mathieu
j'ai l'impression humidité un peu monte
en puissance mais ce n'est un peu de
pression peut-être il n'a pas l'habitude
de jouer à ce niveau et harry krishna
est un peu en dessous pourtant sans un
très bon joueur c'est mon camarade de
club à amiens et je m'attendais à mieux
de sa part ils ont un peu ils ont un peu
craqué du coup heureusement qu'ils ont à
landéhen piccone roues qui ont mené
l'équipe joue très très forte
ouais mais hier tu vas là encore laissé
échapper quand même un avantage
contraire musique zouk et c'est la
joueuse préférée de loeb
koné roues non chérie va en fait on
avait fait une conférence s'est vu un
champion de france à nancy une
conférence entre avec certains des
joueurs du national et il avait dit que
sa joueuse pro d2 c'était koné en toi
qui jouent super bien joué vraiment bien
elle est maman elle a eu un bras en
moins de deux ans je pense hélas elle
est revenue et elle a elle a montré
qu'elle avait la cage ou encore là elle
est très très forte elle est d'ailleurs
dans les premières des grand prix
féminin on pourrait bien tuer voilà
c'est non mais les autres se qualifier
pour un titre de championne du monde et
jouent and june en parlant de championne
du monde qui au quatrième échiquier de
la chine fetaf avec willy fans
franchement là rien à envier à la numéro
un mondiale
ouais ouais les deux sont monstrueuses
non oui oui normes et les deux sont
fortes
j'ai l'impression qu'il est que des
victoires peut-être me trompe sais pas
j'ai pas tout regardé mais enfin si j'ai
vu les partis mais je me rappelle quand
elles ont nécessité une ou deux nuls
mais oui c'est à dire ok ça a été
impressionnant
mais c'est le gros point fort de la
chine celle-ci kevin na et le sortant
ils ont peu de faiblesses et ils ont des
joueurs qui ont l'habitude à part ding
quai juste fort et cas pas trop
l'habitude internet mais qui est juste
fort et en plus qui c'est vachement
entraîné récemment il a fan autres
tournois et les autres ils ont toujours
joué un peu sur internet c'est plus des
plus jeunes générations internet même
s'ils sont en chine mais ils sont
vraiment impressionnants les chinois liu
yang wei qui a qui a la meilleure perte
de la compétition je crois ou le plus de
points avec cinq points et demi mais ça
m'a surpris ce genre monsieur mlu ya pas
si longtemps il était top 10 mondial
on y pense dans le jardin c'est un super
joueur donc on va regarder un petit peu
mathieu le valais ont regardé la con les
propositions c'est le match décisif on
va vous expliquer juste après pourquoi
avec le classement est papa de bluff les
états unis qui nous sortent bas l'équipe
max l'équipe type
donc il m'a acheté vachier lagrave
contre hikaru nakamura
ça va envoyer sévère j'ai l'impression
qu'on a vu cent mille facettes partie
seulement ouais j'ai l'impression qu'on
est rarement du bon côté du manche
je n'aime pas trois semaines j'ai juste
entendu l'autre jour nous avoir raconté
ce match pénible pour nous de protester
oui on peut parler avec romain avec qui
il a dîné mulhouse avait pas du tout
l'équipe à lui tout seul c'est ça c'est
simplement au deuxième échiquier on va
avoir
match très bon match car one avec les
noirs contre les vannes et je trouve une
très bonne décision de garry kasparov au
troisième et chic et j'ai foncé j'ai
pensé aussi je suis assez d'accord parce
que d'oudaï peut vraiment terme
oui c'est il peut gagner d'ailleurs il a
apporté plus de points que guy 1,2 point
entier je veux dire mais là on a deux
ans d'être solide en fait notre objectif
moi je le vois aux quatre nanas pour moi
est plus forte
winona 11 elle peut raser il rit nage
pas si mal que dans ce tournoi j'ai
l'impression en gros l'objectif c'est de
ces d'avoir mvele et aniche qui te
sortent de nulle avec les noirs ils ne
sont plus que capables les bones est
l'électron libre du match c'est ça il
peut tout faire un
il peut tout faire et nana janis et qui
met poids en vo la stratégie aller
simple après il va quand même falloir la
réaliser parce que tenir hikaru nakamura
et wesley so c'est pas une mince affaire
pour guy mvl sera une grosse bercy fonds
a sur 2 et après les bonnes et je perds
contre le numéro deux mondial qui est un
monstre en rapide sur internet
fabiano qui a été extraordinaire et
brink a surtout énormément progressé oui
parce qu'il ya quelques années on aura
dit à rognan favori maintenant andy
carroll va falloir les personnages
favoris il a été très bon pronostic très
bon magnus invitationnal très bon ici
donc et dernier tournoi rapide sur
internet
il est très très fort donc c'est
vraiment une partie compliquée pour les
vannes est derrière au dernier échiquier
nana admise et qui elle a joué comme en
moyens antalya l'a fait un peu des deux
la fée du loup et du moins bon j'ai vu
une très mauvaise partie l'autre jour
c'est que la chine
ouais c'est contre joué john key avait
fait une partie exceptionnelle joue il
avait des chiens mais oui non chassés
d'accord peau de dames même si c'est le
mot un pote 1
d'ailleurs je l'avais fait venir à
cannes pop star je viens d'aller scruter
la vo regoûter mais bon il est un peu
instable en plus serrés avec les morts
qui m'a dit ça on 3oh 3 il a laissé les
noirs de guérir est donc donc non c'est
normal la coupo annick se voyait très
bon choix
à leurs attentes
deux petites choses à faire le
classement à regarder mathieu quand même
pour expliquer vraiment pourquoi ce
match est si important tout simplement
la victoire est à deux points il reste
deux matches la chine est déjà qualifié
pour la finale puisque les deux points
précieux l'inter est donc là usa europe
ont ce point 10 points victoire
obligatoire si on perd voilà fini manu
ne suffit pas non plus une nul suffira
pas les américains qui vont enchaîner
après celle contre qui jouent derrière
mais de toute façon on gagne on est dans
mes parents du coup le temps des matches
si l'europe gagner j'avais bien beau
mais non c'est comme le roc
si l'europe gagne la dernier match sera
important parce qu'il n'aura pas l'eau
pas le droit à l'erreur non n'aura pas
voir les rats mais on va dire que de
toute façon condition sinequanone on
doit gagner ce match mais c'est à dire
que nul c'est pas terrible on n'est pas
mort
un nul c'est pas terrible on n'est pas
mais peut-être y joue la chine l'an
dernier mais peut-être nul peut suffire
mais le truc c'est qu'ils ont un
meilleur goal avérage que nous donc ils
peuvent se permettre de faire mieux
contre la chine ah non on va dire qu'il
faut la gagner il faut le gagner ce
match mathieu ouais je suis pas je pense
que nu c'est pas si mal
ce qui joue la chine la chine même en
roue libre les chinois ils vont ne
pouvait pas perdre un mois et non c'est
vrai mais bon et en plus a augmenté
chinois tu préfères un jouet qui en
finale si je chinois ont eu lieu saint
ouais si je suis chinois chez la guerre
commerciale à tout le monde c'est parce
qu'ils ont ils ont intérêt à battre les
jets salage à l'air pur pour pas les
jouer en finale oui non c'est vrai c'est
vrai mais bon on va quand même partir
sur une victoire pour notre destin entre
les mains et c'est un groupe à si on
termine ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on
sera 3e quoi qu'il se passe
non alors mathieu on va tout doucement
aller vers le match qui va qui va
commencer dans une minute juste les gars
j'ai besoin de quelques secondes pour
avoir les caméras bien comme il faut de
notre maxime nationale et de et di caro
donc donnez moi une petite
bon de réglages et on va se plonger avec
avec mathieu dans le match alors ça va
arriver
il a l'air en forme d'un petit maxime
des fois il est plus fatigué de son
écran il a l'air motivé et voilà c'est
parti mathieu c'est parti avec hikaru
dans sa maintenance célèbre tous là bas
cela bien sûr mais on en droit qui est
célèbre à shekau cette fameuse chambre
rouge luiz priva mais normal on voit on
voit moins sa bibliothèque non
d'habitude mais ils avaient si rémy ses
trophées aujourd'hui et là il a une
petite tati carouge qu'on lui a l'air un
peu fatigué oui la jeune sauf des
changes
bon ça c'est quand même beaucoup plus
venimeux qui me parut baiia du venin
noms qui jouent faux f5 la ligne un peu
à la mode un b3 normalement donc d'un
macaque food et cette dame c'est 2 6
donc on va voir mathieu à la sortie
après ce coup aussi son rapport faire le
vautour celui d'abord mais ça change par
le schmilblick donc l'énorme enjeu si ce
tour c'est 8 sortir le fouet soit on
paie 400 e set
donc en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
avec damas quatre échecs les blancs ou
perdu un temps entre guillemets sûr
qu'ils ont forcé le fou au f5 et du bon
côté de la chaîne de pion à s'enfermer
un peu quelque part en 17
alors on va expliquer pourquoi après e6
mathieu voilà maintenant le fou le fou
est derrière la structure de pions on a
mis un peu enfermé par contre en échange
il dans les coins or-azur un cavalière à
5 est plutôt bien placé pour la case c4
et le fou en dix-sept qu'il n'y a qu'un
seul but on va pouvoir de tours ces 8es
jeux sur cette colonne s'est donc c'est
une preuve 5 c'est un couple était censé
égaliser puis les blancs se trouver
cette idée d'un mât 4 est intéressant
donc ici aussi des idées à passe de
cavalia chacun jours d' essayer de
gratter sous mais il faut toujours se
faire guère contre 5 un coup comme fou
de 5
il peut créer un affaiblissement sont
faibles 6 et après on repart en g3 je
sais que toi je t'ai vu souvent faire
cette manoeuvre dans ta nantais trompeau
dans des systèmes de londres ouais
mais arrange pas du tout à part rien ne
le dérangent et l3 normalement on fait
d'or s'est vite ici donc juste pour
expliquer mathieu simplement position
symétrique au centre aoua symétrique
total des pierres ont peut être moins
symétrique de la structure parce qu'on a
changé les plans c mais les blancs qui
veulent prétendre un avantage parce que
le fou 17 ne rayonne pas il est bloqué
dans la chaîne de pions et le x 4 est
passé devant je redis ce que tu dis mais
de manière on va dire aux échecs il ya
un truc est très intéressant pour savoir
comment évaluer une position quand le
matériel est égal c'est de comparer les
pièces une par une et si on compare le
rayonnement des pièces ont ce que tu dis
ah c'est exactement ça le faux airs 4 a
l'air mieux du moins que le fou 17 oui
mais regardons qu'avait dh 5 c'est là
tout de suite et challenges le fond au
point la paire degrés ce petit avantage
mais donc fossat qui veut provoquer f6
donc ça qu'il faut vérifier si m6 il ya
foule g3 j'imagine mais il faut regarder
fou prend hachette jeunesse 6 5
c'est hyper chaud c'est en dur ok mais
c'est peut-être une prépare de maxime
serait la bonne nouvelle
il a fait faux sac tu penses que c'est
théorique mathieu oui c'est théorique
c'est pas si cons les gens comprennent
que vaut-elle pas de quoi on parle c'est
juste que j'ai fait quelques vidéos je
disais que c'était seulement théorique
le coup logique c'est fou j'ai 3 c'est
le plus grand d un des plus grands
spécialistes de la théorie en france et
a été champion de france pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas agen en 2016 16 à 23
ans autres catégories
oui c'était un bon souvenir parce
contempler j'étais dans ma région comme
chu de bordeaux
c'est sympa donc fou g3 s'intéressant
cette position parce que s cachette est
vraiment présent j'ai envie de dire
plutôt week
mais on aimerait bien le laisser à
prolonger trois on n'a pas trop envie
d'ouvrir le la tour parce que maintenant
h est comprise trois fois et là ça
ferait un peu peur et on aurait pas de
g6 pour couvrir aknin four en justice
oui le pion hsv clowe et enfin suite à
la fin si on reprend donc qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ici réd la vraie
question c'est est-ce que c'est vraiment
une menace est ce qu'on peut jeu tour
c'est 8
s'il faut prendre un chef est ce qu'il
ya une combine je n'en vois pas c'est à
t'as pas envie de jouer a alors tu peux
tenter de jouer comme ça et jouer sur le
courage genre maintenant tout bouge le
roi alors puisqu'il a et menacerait
poser six échecs monstres et menacerait
je sais pas si clair selon lequel ces
quatre peut-être pour mes insectes et
prendre des deux va me prendre une heure
pour montrer à la combinaison genre sur
un coup lambda comme relais fin on
pourrait faire caler prend b2 d'un
projet de four en c3 on serait protégé
ici ça marcherait pas il faut laisser
ces dames un drôle de danse pour montrer
l'idée à alléger contre et en dv mais
maxime qui a décidé de jouer f5 raison
que j'aime pas du tout je déteste ça ça
donne déjà fou et 5 et une option
fouache quatrième fois à ce qu'elle juge
ne comprend pas l'idée je remets ton
père et fils cette logique mais du coup
le fou en fait en imprimant 1,5 et le
fou de gaze noire et qu'on aime qu'on
voulait changer entre guillemets mais on
n'a pas écrit non ça c'est typique des
matines qui séparent après sa prépa je
le connais mon maximum et j'ai
l'impression que dans ces slave qui
s'est mis à jouer il ya peu ça fait un
mois qu'il les joue non il n'a pas
toujours les bons réflexes
ouais ok il ya aussi un truc ils jouent
tous les jours il n'a pas le temps de
bosser juste le seul jour où il ya le
repos il n'a peut-être pas envie dehors
encore regarder c'est cela il s'est dit
je vais la prendre sur le tas en jouant
comme ce soir et pendant que le plus
important alors alors qu'ils car on est
en train de regarder son téléphone
portable c'est pas faux
le chat
enfin il donnait l'impression voyez pas
à l'écran mais ça qui donne l'impression
de regarder quelque chose non si c'est
une personne on pense que fair play
c'est vraiment un cas au point mort mais
y arrière ya aucun aucun risque à mon
avis de quelques pour ceux qui
connaissent pas les échecs c'est vrai
qu'on peut demander
quid de la triche aux échecs s'auto sur
internet et oui c'est un vrai problème
mais là on parle du top niveau ils ont
tous la webcam
il ya le partage d'écran où il ya un
partage qui elle partage d'écran
donc c'est sûr qu'il n'ya aucune triche
après pour des tournois plus avec
beaucoup plus de mots et pas forcément
les meilleurs joueurs du monde c'est ça
peut être un problème malheureusement
oui exactement là c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas de doute parce que c'est hikaru
nakamura qu'il a une réputation que con
qu'on connaît le bonhomme etc mais mais
c'est vrai que ça c'est signer si les
gens ne connaissent pas je sais pas si
on a déjà parlé c'est qu'il a une chaîne
switch qui est qu'est ce qui est assez
marrant qu'un stream tous les jours
il est tout le temps là il va injecter
que les dés que les partis sont finies
là le soir il fait sur cette chaîne
switcher le débrief des parties du jour
l'un l'alignement j'ai très marrant mais
a su f5 c'est vrai que c'est très être
raté gicm en même temps fou le 5 juin
faux seins que ces thématiques aussi un
tueur place sucre vers leur a tant il
vient de jouer hikaru il vient de jouer
à trois sa belle cette tablette manqué
le truc c'est que normalement m'étais
jeté mois d'hôpital je te rappelle je te
disais tour c'est une force de vie
maintenant si tu prends ces trois jeux
prend pas des pions comme toi et tu es
obligé à prendre comme ça ensuite je
peux prendre de la dame juste parce que
plus intéressant parce que tu en prends
ça permettrait de faire justement tour
ces 8es jouer mais même ça je pense
qu'on est mieux au foot et 6 pins très
bizarre très bizarre de jouer comme ça
mais bon hein maximilien il a fait une
ouverture kata contre thing et
d'ailleurs je connais c'est un truc que
je comprends vos élèves
c'était horrible mais j'ai joué ça
contre quand un oiseau
cette maxime qui est mon pays qu'il a
fuit les options en armée qui a qui
quand même remonté d'une position comme
il était sûrement bien en tête quand
adam kszczot oui oui mais a préféré les
remontées d'une position des enfers moi
j'étais sûr qu'il allait perdre acheter
du jeu donnait un cours je regardais en
diagonale bon là je pense qu'il doit
moi je repartirai donc genre cette
saison
mais si je tu peux pas ouais tu aimerais
bien mais tu peux pas donc au passage tu
pourrais peut-être noté un truc comme
qu'étrangers 3 ça ça peut être
instructif a montré qu' on prend donc
mais aussi les attaques en plus la tour
faut des six il y aura sans doute g4 qui
donnera un avantage au bout qui
permettrait pour l alberta nominal ça
peut être une idée pour les blancs mais
d'ailleurs dans le cas présent sur tous
les points dont trois aces que je peux
pas faire apprendre des quatre quais
francs achat
je peux en fait ça doit le plus gagnant
2 et je vais chercher cavaliers qui peut
pas son île peut pas sortir la cage est
roi et où elle de son contrôle et donc
donc les blancs on doit avoir de pièce
pour la tour donc ils vont être camion
donc il a fait fouet cette note maximale
et donc c'est le coût que j'attendais
donc là on s'attend à foule ça il faut s
inquiètent plus au gic 1 mais j'ai radio
5 serait plus immature mouais mais si je
rock
en fait je vais attendre que tu rock et
tu dis que tu vas rauque et je te prends
je te prends
comment tu sors se fout si elle doit
atteindre tout petit peu mieux mais on a
connu pire
on a connu maxime il a connu bien sa vie
je suis obligé surveillance et s'ils
souhaitent voir les dépositions comme ça
d un peu moins bien mais bat aura les
ruptures g4 pour attaquer leurs ouvrages
moi je me posais la question de songer 4
pourquoi pas justice au point donc
normalement quand même plutôt fou et 5
mathieu plutôt flou 5
après faut 5 pc si non il faut cinq
lycées 6 h 3o g4 donc là en fait on est
prêt à donner le food cases noires à
quand on a les blancs mais pour jouer
sur case blanche parce que
j'écarte au prochain coup et le roi est
fluide peut avoir un problème puis on
achète c'est un gros souci et le
cavalier c3 qui peut rejaillir un jour
en 2 4 pour revenir encore appuyé sur
blanc de partout quoi et une vanne le
fou 17 ça absolument rien à part un
défend de 6 le faux le 7 mai en fait il
est joli mais en fait ils tapent nulle
part alors le plan à trois c'est pas
vraiment spécial du tout miss est rare
ayant qu'elle se fout donc là dans ces
cas là quand votre adversaire info de
cases noires il vous en avez pas tous
des jeux sur lesquels blanche a
peut-être samedi
d'ailleurs food et s'ils se font prendre
5 e mathieu excuse moi de te couper mais
ça peut être une idée oui j'allais
j'allais venir ce genre d'idées est
bonne
le problème c'est qu'un cavalier h5
quand les blancs font des 4 prend 2,5
par exemple montre georges et 4 vas-y tu
peux jouer les quatre le marché oui moi
je voulais juste montrer monsieur falaki
manager 4 qui l'on peut faire j'ai
quatre d'abord s'il faut prendre un
simple s'il faut prendre 5 juste dé
prendre 5 gagné une pièce et le cavalier
sur le bord mal placé donc de prendre 5
ça prend énormément de temps on va voir
ramené le canadien arrive si c'est
peut-être un plan après ça peut être car
il y avait six rock foo 1,8 bon je vais
montrer un joug découlant d'un mathieu
par l'un de ses membres ont pour les
blancs d'air je vais faire des coups qui
servent à rien une idée ça peut être de
se remettre comme ça l'un on serait
encore un tout petit peu moins bien mais
ça devrait aller
mais ça a demandé de jouer trois coups
qui servent à rien pour les blancs c'est
pour vous montrer à quel point la
pollution moi qui paraît pourtant assez
logique peut être un peu dangereux après
c'est pas non plus ah bon nous abordons
je pense que ce refus le 5 il veut
revenir à m6 pour empêcher g4 et h3
besoin je crois cavaliers 6 4 et 1 coupe
mais 4g 4 j'aime pas trop tarder 5 ça
marche pas et que c'est cette attaque
c'est sûr que ça marche en france et 8
ans et 2 prend la saq en d2 c'est le
compte de matériel également compliqué
donc ducrocq meubles bon du coup si on
réfléchit
hume et engrossé position qui est mieux
pour nakamura c'est clair mais c'est pas
si simple de trouver la voie qui
maintient qui donne un avantage est
requis et prend des cinq direct peut
aussi être une chose qui calcule en tant
qu'étranger 3 kgs ses sept bougies
quant à lui un peu points 8 qui prend un
chien dames c'est cette notule inscrit
un nom rigolo
au pire tu sortiras en je pense pas que
six à sortir mon cavalier ou je prends
ce qu'ils veulent je chausse un mois il
faut ça que c'est le coup le plus
logique à mathieu mais ça qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui est fait est normal dans
le choc qui me fait beaucoup rire
il neige les deux cavaliers mevel oui
c'est vrai que mes deux carrés sur le
bord et on se demande si quelqu'un
demande s'il a fait un pari avec botez
c'est possible c'est possible on fait un
petit tour des échiquiers jusqu'à le
surnommer renonce à cesser la partie
importante que j'aime bien les blancs
alors je fais un passage rapide depuis
un terme à une chaîne espagnole d3100
qu'on fasse de pause 1 c'est juste pour
voir comment on est arrivé jusque là
donc c'est une espagnole la foulée 5e
vous qui caractérise l ouverture
espagnol mathieu heleven qui est un
grand qu'il est réaliste
le cargo n'a pas juif ou c5 il a joué
aux candidats plusieurs fois donc evans
qui est complètement passé à eux quatre
avec les blancs mois sur tombait donc à
kério 2 hc pas se rappelle c'était il y
avait eu la partie du carlton par
cassano maxime contre jean guy l'avais
pas j'aurais eu de mai que les deux
c'est le coût que moi j'avais dit dans
la vidéo j'avais fait de porc toi
derrière que c'était une bonne façon de
jouer que jamais bien que je trouve ça
plus logique d'amener le cabinet sur la
droite parce que le fond de baisse est
maintenant fait pas grand chose j'aime
beaucoup les blancs mais il faut être
sûr que ça marche parce que le prince
est que si on n'arrive pas à bien
attaquer ben le fou p7 un jour que
j'aurai le food et 8 pour ressortir par
exemple si le foot peut être dans le
cinq ça serait sans doute bien pour les
noirs mais prince et quand des 8es il
est enfermé dans que l'objectif des
blancs ça va être deux en qu'on en est
lé plus de place sur les droits et
d'empêcher le food et 8 de rentrer en
jeu
donc si on fait dans
damas 3 tours f1 je ferai ça ou d'amd de
avec la même idée de taquiner
enrichissent juste pour que ce soit
visuel mathieu quand on voyait la
regarder les blancs ils ont une pièce
deux pièces trois pièces 4 pièces cinq
pièces six pièces ils ont toutes leurs
pièces qui joue sur le petit carré
d'échiquier où se trouve le roi noir
donc ça c'est vraiment l'idée des plants
matures et concrètement la menace quand
on fera tout ça ça serait de sacrifier
le cavalier f5 angers 7 où 1 h is et de
prendre en m6 et du coup on a sacrifié
une qualité donc une qualité ce qu'on
appelle une qualité aux échecs c'est une
porte ou une pièce mineurs mais ici par
exemple y aurait dame justice le pion à
vii est cloué le coupé 3 3h suite on
prendrait enrichissent et après on
ramène la tour où le cavalier sénat
direct kg 5 d'un match est tout aussi
joli tout matt tout mat
donc perso après avec l'énoncé que ces
coins là donc il va pas se laisser faire
webb avec l'énoncé levana organes donc
que faire avec les noirs normalement la
ses positions en a marre bien je veux
des cinq mais ici on parle j'y crois
j'ai un mois sans que ça ne marche pas
du tout il ya au 5 la lie à l'option qui
rejoint l' attaquent la carélie qui va
pouvoir prendre un fils malade tu as
trop chic ça pulse est l'électron libre
et on est encore dans trafton est en
train d' encore frappé matthieu daele le
seul truc car on a joué assez vite donc
faut espérer qu'ils connaissent pas qui
l'a juste d'être allé juste moins fort
que je reste email mais je pense
vraiment que c'est bien pour les bleus
honnêtement à croquer prince schiste
sarabi de qualité long terme on va
s'appeler contentant g5 il ya quoi j'ai
5 c'est de l'eau matures je viens vite
craqué quelque chose ici puis on prend
d'un match trois cavaliers h7 tu te
situes roi g8 tu peux le montrer il ya
des machines qui doit matin par un je
pense pas que j'espère c'est que j'ai vu
qu'à value8 dame décision
[Musique]
six épreuves c'est bien c'est tu me
laisses ta machine d'un match huit
matches on va c'est vraiment un peu
compliqué mais c'est pour voir que ça
m'as tu as mais non mais du coup
quelques rangées 5 salaires dangereux
battues auquel il pourra aussi se
soucier peut-être jouable aurait pas mal
mais ton g4 pour donner à la qualité et
pas bête aussi
non mais j'ai 5 il fera jamais g5 c'est
beaucoup trop dangereux il suffit qu'il
ait oublié quelque chose d'hyper tôt
plus il fera jamais j'ai 5 ans surtout
en match en équipe
normalement tu es censé être un tout
petit peu plus frais leur équipe puisque
tu joues au pote que porto puis tu veux
pas perdre rapidement tu mets tout le
monde en danger mathieu miaka très chic
et on doit on doit tourner pour voir un
peu ce qui se massent te faire une pause
général c'est guy avec les noirs ma foi
il faut juste faire pas se faire dominer
comme la partie que tu avais commenté
d'ailleurs je pense car quarantaine
ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai que général
faut prendre des 5 et après arriver à
faire un bon timing pour the beast qui a
et b 7 qui a aidé si ce nom mais sow
sera tenté de le dominer dans cette
position mais mais annie j'aimerais mais
annie chine est dans son rôle de
bloqueur je suis confiant ça me rassure
pour l'instant je suis plutôt satisfait
donc et donc il nous reste n'a pas
toujours empreinte de pseudo ça va ça va
j'ai appris ok je préfère toujours les
blancs mais c 'est toujours solide par
contre c'est quoi un écho lointain
penser à un eto'o tu vas roxy un
policier juste rapidement dans la
structure de pionsat perdons c'est très
solide pour les normes et les blancs
sont toujours un peu mieux parce qu'ils
ont plus d espace aux échecs espace est
très important ici pourquoi on préfère
les blancs parce que les noirs ils ont
du mal à trouver du contre je alors
qu'est-ce que du contrat jeu ça pourrait
être une rupture et les ruptures ici ça
serait b5 et ici les blancs ont très
bien joué parce qu'il contrôle très bien
cette case avec le point à 4 depuis ses
4 lequel ces trois une structure des 5
alors si c'est encore pire
là on est en
parfois f5 c'est possible mais ça serait
quand même affaiblir son propre droit
c'est toujours comme le problème l'on se
pose la question s'est prise et dames
c'est simple ce qu'elle a prévu mais je
pense que la réponse écueil dessins
auxquels la carrer les dessins qui a eu
l'idée d'attaquer la cac et prend des 5e
prendre 8 5
ça c'est l'écho nationale pour les plans
en le plan ici il est simple on fait
tourner un tour trois tours ou ont déjà
tu doubles et après tu peux a balancé
ton pion à 20 h 4 h 5
après associe toujours lieu pour les
blancs macha elle est jouée la colonne h
attaqué le chien ghetto en général les
noirs dans ces cas là ils doivent
essayer de jeu aussi mais le problème
c'est qu'après la prise ça ils vont se
retrouver avec deux pions des très
faibles
oh là là ça serait vraiment pas bon
concrètement parce que le puits on se
remplit donc aux qualifs site pour moi
au 17e coup la scala je sais tu es moins
bien après qu'elle ait des saints qui
ont longuement bataillé cinq sets vous
je t'aime pour un cahier prend le prend
et puis après je réfléchirai
après tu peux te dire que calais son
prochain coup eux si ce n'est pas une
manade puisque adam 3 m6 qu'est ce que
tu peux pas en profiter un coup part
manger 3g 2 h 4 en longue peut-être mais
en rapide je me poserai pas trop la
question
non je comprends ton point de vue après
est ce qu'elle peut pas avoir peur de l
a fait l a fait c'est bien donc
au passage c'est important peut-être de
préciser que c'est vraiment important de
prendre 2 e
parce que le pion le 7 c'est la
faiblesse et le pion et les arriérés on
appelle ça il est en arrière de la
structure il peut pas être défendue par
un autre pion donc c'est juste un petit
avantage blanc sans risque ok c'est donc
pour l'instant fait c est que maxime ou
on aime pas trop alors voilà c'est ce
que j'avais proposée mathieu je propose
qu'on retourne sur maxime parce que ça
semble être une partie vraiment décisif
dans ce match
les américains ont besoin de marquer et
hikaru nakamura a besoin de mettre à mal
de dos noir français mais maxime qui n'a
toujours pas perdu dans son nom à
mathieu tu noteras qu'on n'a rien
compris la position
bon alors c'est ou alors on a des
raisons ils ont tant mais il sait peut
passer du tout ce qu'on avait prévu
donc le cavalier a réussi à rester en a
5 est en achat c'est quand même beau
c'est un challenge en soi
la prison j'ai trop hâte maintenant une
option parce que la colonne h hne à
tournehem plus sur la colonne h
le cahier à 5 à la casse sekkat le food
et c'est donc très important ça sans
qu'aucun caballos un conte peugeot 2 x 8
qui qui va défendre en même temps le cac
va les acheter et qui protège toutes les
cases entre guillemets d'entrée du
cavaly fait ce qu'on a eu la fameuse
case faux calme mais le cavalier qui est
complètement dominé parfum dominé le fou
qui en tout cas permet d'empêcher toute
velléité offensive du cavalier très bien
placé non mais j'ai l'impression
maximilien petit totem d'immunité cette
semaine il est franchement plus je
regarde la pollution que je pense qu'il
s'est rapproché de l'égalité les succès
4 1 qui peut exister dont on n'a pas du
tout pareil hein ça j'aime pas l'amour
le bon temps aux normes ce qui a peut
être qu'ils avaient libre en est que ça
va affaiblir mais tu vois on y met même
pourquoi ouvrir se fout des trois pas
pour le moment mais si un jour tu fait
cavalier s'écarte pourquoi f4 ça pourra
rester dans l'air suivant et fiscale je
laime plus là qu'un pion g5 mais pas un
seul qui peut jamais joué j'ai cinq ici
tant que le pomerol ce donc là c'est
assez intéressant donc fou 8 un peu de
prophylaxie mesquin tout comme dan b6 te
tenterait non parce que pour moi la dame
pour rester plutôt au centre
j'ai toujours peur de je les ai droit en
fait mon cavalier au sein qui s'il
faudra regarder mes cinq sens d'un v6
qui avait lieu saint avold 8 qui reprend
des cinq ans donc ça serait juste une
gaffe en fait un problème j'arrête pour
ses limites
attends ça joue mathieu il ya eu
cavaliers franges et 3h pranger 3 es fou
des six oui tout d'abord ok j'aime bien
en gros on avait parlé de cette idée on
va le prendre et mène le fond des
schistes mais tout à l'heure la toa est
un achat il y avait du g4 donc là c'est
beaucoup beaucoup plus logique mais ça
alors ok to b 5 ça à mathieu je peux
juste pas comprendre parce que on a déjà
parlé de nakamura on a déjà commenté des
matches picard ou ensemble et tu disais
qu'il était bizarre avec les bons ou les
mauvais fou parce que là on ne les
comprend pas été mauvais pour juste pour
expliquer ce qu'un mauvais fou parce
qu'il tape danser
production et maxime les change pas
écoute alors là ils sont beaucoup plus
forts que moi mathieu je comprends pas
dans mes cheveux je vais t'expliquer si
audi a6 son idée c'est de prendre et de
mettre un cavalier en a eu cinq ma mémé
je le croyais en moi je te regarde
ah non c'était pas cavaler aux saintes
il faut trouver peut-être le timing
qu'est ce que tu peux je dis papa
jacques avait bien 4 que tu peux faire
ainsi et b1 et bien que c'est moi
j'aurais fait à six médecins j'ai pas
vraiment compris parce que pour moi le
cavalier sekkat paraissait une menace à
long terme mais c'est eux qui
comprennent quelque chose qu'on comprend
pas un faux pour être mais en précisant
pour eux pour revenir un truc sur
l'histoire des fous non je pense juste
que senna kaka ex puisque faire couper
cinq voiliers fin logiquement en match
on a pas mal parlé mais l'idée de faire
j'écarte faire rayonner de fouet attaqué
droit c'est un truc classique se fout 17
on voit bien qu'il est moche
il tape dans du poids il est juste en
train d'échanger une pièce qui pourrait
s'ouvrir à l'attack mais maxime refuse
cet échange mais après il le refuse mais
pas forcément pour trait tu peux je
cavaliers ou 7 au prochain par non mais
je vois pas l'intérêt de le refuser
pour moi c'est pas normal parce qu'elle
est censée femme paraissait partir pour
ces quatre mois après et est donc là par
un fou prend ses six pour être une idée
vraiment ça par contre je peux le
comprendre
fo prend cavalier e 5 et l'objectif
après cet échange c'est de jouer
cavalier contrefout c6 et d'un bon café
les contraindraient fou mais même ça
concrètement je suis même pas sûre qu'on
consomme moins bien que pour emmener le
cabinet en d4
on va passer par une case qui est pas un
fou d'allah il a joué tour c'est de
regarder à gauche l'évaluation de
l'ordinateur est toujours proche de
l'égalité dont il est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle
moi honnêtement je ferait cavalier à 5
macharia 5 paraît logique
ah si j'aimerais pas trop parce que tu
viens de regroupement il fera jamais
fait à 520 écossais qui nécessiteront
mais juste c'était pour la blague
objectivement je pense que c'est comme
beaucoup de projets la caraïbe et invite
aussi mais c'est
bizarre ayvaz faire foot et 3 suivi de
toute façon je pense qu'il a joué à 1,6
c'est super et au dans la gc je t'avoue
que je n'ai vraiment pas compris la
séquence
non mais après il faut pas oublier que
nous on est tranquille à la maison on
n'a pas de pression et on a un petit
module qui peut tourner si on a besoin
pour voir si on n'y pas de grosses
bêtises mais je suis persuadé que
qu'elle sait si ces poubelles 5
n'étaient pas les meilleurs coups même
s'ils sont beaucoup plus forts comment
on peut se permettre on peut se
permettre aux albres donc un hôte aussi
gros avantage autant pour maxime qui a
dix minutes de plus qui carreaux et
karoutchi je sais pas j'ai l'impression
gare la caméra qui dit quelque chose
west un réseau notre sens qu'il en a
rien à [ __ ]
c'est très étrange parce qu'il joue bien
dans cette compétition
alors après il a l'air très fatigué
aussi ce que tu as dit directement
n'avait inscrit que déjà pas comme
d'habitude la mairie car en plus il ay
là il a reposé quelque chose c'est comme
s'il avait un téléphone et il lisait des
messages et leurs poses et ça va
vraiment cette impression
maxime tanguay qui ne joue pas son idée
c'est simplement de faire j'ai cote de
fixer la structure après moi je peux te
dire que j'ai été aussi étonné qu'ils
caroux soit pas encore en surmenage
parce que ça fait depuis deux semaines
qui passent dix heures par jour entre
les stream qu'il fait les compétitions
qui jouent juste avait l'attention du
dernier tour - oui 50 ans met d'ailleurs
en fait les membres menace d'être mieux
parce que j'ai 4
si t'as pas la case aux cinq je te fais
un chien cachent quatre baies comme
tapasu de cadenas avec les blancs tu
peux te faire attaquer sont comme moi
donc peut-être que c'est le moment de
jeu français si ses cavaliers aux 5es de
tout échange et peut-être que les noirs
veulent jouer les 8es pas prendre
prendre la tour
vraiment hors cac valeo 5 il va faire
fou prend et
il va jouer g4g 4 pour quand les blancs
monts faire 4 pour défendre avec un pion
s'obtient au sein qui veulent prendre en
passant ça doit être ça son son idée
gens mais même ça f4 ça donne quoi ça
qui me prend je prends pas clair ouais
mais ça ne l'est pas la fin du monde
l'âme j'ai cinq tours fc un g4
je comprends pas je comprend aucun pouce
est assez drôle non parce que là je vous
explique la différence y ont fait
cavaliers aux 5
je veux prendre est attaqué depuis un
jour d'amd 87 quel est ton projet cette
dame c'est cet humain 2,4 ok j'avais pas
vu et prend même à 22.5 je suis pas
moins bien light attaque le fou et adam
g 5 échecs ses salines
mais je suis aussi assez de la manière
de faim jeu nettement ce qu'il a fait
car ailleurs mais en fait y'a que d'un
coup je te jure que je ne comprends pas
ce que carey ok voilà j'ai l'impression
qu'elle n'en ressent bien je jouais à
chaque âge qu'adam g suntour f6 je suis
hyper étonné en fait de la partie mais
plus j'ai envie de dire ça ça plutôt une
bonne tournure
ouais ça tourne plutôt bien mais disons
joué d'une manière
mais voilà même ce genre de type i qu'on
apprendrait même s'ils ont tort en fait
ils tant dans le sens où ce n'est pas le
meilleur
c'est sans doute en a un côté pratique
que nous on comprend pas bien mais moi
ici mais les noirs hk 3 et 7 tours h ou
8 h 4 4 le jeune cavalier cap c'est que
j'ai l'impression que ouais ben tu veux
mon cas mais je sais qu'en fait alors un
messi qui a valu au sein de ces aucun
sourire oui je sais dupuis lecavalier f4
mais en fait je te prendrai jamais en f4
obligé de faire bref cette grève c'est
un péché sachent qu alger 6 tu viens
quand même des rangs investir trois
coups pour faire quelque chose qui est
pas forcément
fouet bah tant mieux on prend six
n'accueille dangereux avec des cavaliers
après avoir un côté pratique on a un
truc qui nous échappe ça j'en suis sûre
est assez mature mais hockey plutôt
bonne
on peut faire un petit tour sur
l'apartheid à rognan c'était celle qui
nous intéresse alors comment il s'en est
sorti avec les normes
segan des magiciens les parties adam r3
je te rassure non ce serait fait mater
oui graff et la fête des 5 où l'on
pensait que 5 qui achètent et ici il a
dû rater entre mais elle a fait des
quatre qui est tellement tentant un des
quatre idées ses stabilisants baujot ces
trois fous ces deux ça c'est bien jouer
c'est sûr fou g5 est là il a fait une
fois qu'il fallait faire d'alger 3 et la
jeune dame gkd montre dames j'ai trois
salles instructif g6 si on joue comme
dans la partie maintenant sacrifier la
qualité cabello trois ont classé leurs
vies qui le trouve un c'est pas moi je
vous rassure faut prendre cavadee prend
il trouve qu'on a vachement de jeu on
fait en attaque le plan des cinq on va
menacer peut-être aussi c'est le pion
justice est en prise on peut ramener la
torah un ondes en attaque avec tours f1
et en fait on a toutes les pièces voir
le roi mais ça c'est en est car ils
étaient 4 au 6 juin du coup il ajou dame
g4 malheureusement même si c'est logique
donc du coup il gagne un pion mais
circuit une qualité pour un pion et
c'est vrai qu'il a l'air mieux mais les
blancs le 6 à faire ce bleu les noirs
aussi à tarte blocus avec ses 6 et à
partir du moment où tu étais si si je me
fous bessette aurait été mauvais donc il
a été très mal en faisant pousser 8
intermédiaire pourra préfère c6 est
maintenant sortir le fou j'en rends f5
donc qualité pour un pion mais ça peut
tourner pas très bon pour nous ouais
j'aime pas trop en franche à la vue du
match plein on n'est pas très contents
d'avoir ça qui rit gherib moi je trouve
qu'il joue très bien quand les cinq pas
tomber cité songes des contrats en fait
le roi blanc est plus faible que le roi
noir en pot il ya aucun problème pour
manquer
[Musique]
l'un de ses seins car ça c'est un truc
normalement c'est juste nouvelle a5 bien
joué d'ailleurs crise prises trop bien
joué bien j'aime bien
lance un bon coup mais j'aurais joué
trop bo a d'abord bien c'est le genre de
petit truc n'est pas très précis et veut
est-ce que la tordre 17 est possible
donc là dans ces cas là on met le
taureau ou trois qui défend b3 on ramène
de trois jara j'aimerais bien voir le
roux en c3 disons la renommée par en
finale le roi est une pièce à part
entière donc il faut la sortir b6 est
pas vraiment une rupture e6 est souvent
en prise dans ces cas là il faut pousser
les pions un aileron h4 créer une créer
un front pour avoir du jeu pour pour
rentrer donc regarder les tournois la
meilleure place magnifique saison 2
c'est un des 8 et c'est très triste que
ça tape sur des cinq au moins la taureau
1 est meilleure qu'elle a elle est bien
meilleure à la taxe est appréciée pas
faire non mais je pense que tu peux
jouer roi f2 h 4g 4 h un match auront le
droit pour à tout moment pour pouvoir
doubler peut-être pas à rouans et 3
passes en passant sur la colonne delio
rossi ce serait pas fait c'est dommage
je pars à commencer par tour
ouais c'est entre brûle et maintenant tu
fais à st c'est ce genre de petite
nuance patrice parisé si grave en soi
bon alors on retourne chez max il
[Musique]
s'était bien joué c'était l'autre option
on n'avait pas mentionné on avait droit
ex tête mais c'est la même idée tout
simplement
alors regardez moi je prendrais ses deux
passes quand après la prise de la dame
10 ont regardé les coquilles à la
colonne c'est mais tu remplaces et bien
vous la colombie à utiliser pour payer a
rentré ça sert à quoi donc disons d'un 9
6 avril a fait près serré l'a repris en
c2 avec la tour même si sa mère 6 en a
même si ce pourquoi pas ce que je peut
menacer de prendre un f4 et si tu prends
deux il ya des prendrait quatre et sinon
je veux simplement faire tout rachète
damas schiste et pranger 3 est rentrée
sur la colonie
après faudra encore maté ainsi pas
encore fait que le roi ait aucun doute
que les noirs sont un peu mieux je veux
juste montrer une nouvelle fois
simplement pas grand chose j'imagine
qu'il va y avoir un moyen de faire
quelque chose tout rage 3 peut-être ça
marche ou pas parce que si tu prends du
cavalier prendre eux aussi l'ont menacé
l'option est sûre cavaliers prend foot
ranger 3 je pensais et puis un jeu 3 et
menaces d'un machin maths sont possibles
mature donc entier pour montrer qu'il ya
vraiment un must
il a fait d'un v6 et on menace la france
f4 moins longues ce que gf ça allait
serait à sa s ur manche et trois la
pollution semble difficile pour hikaru
donc aucun doute que les blancs sont
nuls
oui ok même si tu fais qu'essien qui a
été trop je te ferai tout b5
non mais si c'est mieux pour fin j'ai
aucun autre que les plans sont gagnants
sont devant nous mais hikaru sur la
caméra qui semble vraiment pas dans son
assiette un regard des grilles liliane
comprendre en fait peut-être qu'ils
viennent voir le tour à trois têtes qui
s'est dit les normes ont rien sur la
colonne a en fait si tu vois pastora je
prends enfin que tu viens de montrer
mais peut-être qu'elle dit rien
mon avis c'est sympa de se rendre compte
et il a laissé tomber le portable
il est dans le livre tard il a une
attitude vraiment étrange un la partie
d'aujourd'hui alors oui bien qu'il a un
problème autre que c'est pas du tout son
genre de rapport pour qui regardent le
téléphone comme ça pendant une partie
puisque clairement pour être très très
clair par rapport à son niveau de jeu
etc
il ya zéro pour cent alors mais moins
que zéro que qu'il ait utilisé une aide
extérieure il fait plutôt une très
mauvaise partie et plus il avait l'air
pas concentré de là il est concerné mais
il n'aime pas ça il est plus consternés
que concerné n'est rien ouais et le web
après ce qui est un peu étrange c'est
que s'il a vraiment un problème ils
auraient ils auraient quand même pu
faire je le devine gatefin gère son
remplaçant mauvais mais c'est vrai que
s'ils donnaient l'impression que je suis
c'est interdit du téléphone qu'on n'est
même pas sûr que c'était ça mais en plus
il est lent et déjà mais lang - non mais
ça donnait l'impression qu'il écrivait
le téléphone calme ouais ouais
après après il est possible que s'il est
vraiment
les mines graves ou quoi il y les u11
way d'une exception peut-être qu'il a
vraiment juste quelque chose de grave
c'est possible mais ouais donc tour des
deux parce que parce que le plan des
cats pourrait être un jour en prison ce
que j'expliquais avec 24 ok donc là d'un
machisme
j'ai fixé trois exemptés relâche c'est
ce qui va arriver c'est génial c'est que
si tu regardes leur dis n'importe paul
wolfe torah je suis trop avec ça vous
amuse habite juste d'un match tu fais
quoi j'ai pas exclu l'idée c'est de
partir par là bas je prends je trouvais
prend h cup
je veux de mater à la main dame pour
puisque maintenant tapis d'un effet en
fait c'était ça mon idée que tu peux me
montrer des zecs normalement tu peux pas
prendre un f4 parce qu'il y aurait des
médecins qui défend j'ai deux sûr que le
cahier des cinq est en prison mais
attends je m'entends qu'avec le roi en
fait le truc c'est que je pense à damas
et quand je fais roi des trois pour
partir il ya ma vie en l'air
donc il a fait à 6 maxime quand même il
a voulu éviter que les places manquent
donc donc il n'a pas vu non plus et roy
f7 maintenant mais même là c'est bizarre
non aurait fait revivre cet ouvrage
suite voilà on économisera 80 peut-être
qu'il veut tant attendu quand j'ai
peut-être que le faire dès le début d'un
match 8 ça s'est fait à main je suis
direct en trop
désolé c'est vrai que c'est assez ouvre
sa qualité mathieu de géologie trois
mulets la taille jusqu'aux anglais c'est
maso dans le chat ou quoi non ils
m'appelleront loisy naquit la peau
furent alors dame ses deux mains moi je
rêve a nommé en fait peut-être que
maintenant il ya un sacrifice en dessin
qui peut traîner
j'aurais pas jouer d'un machisme d'un
anarchiste au rejet trois peut-être ça
marche pas des trucs qui avait laissé
trop revient on le 2 maintenant c'est ça
son idée avec del mundo donné la case
pôle cavalli honnêtement axis airways 7
c'était vraiment pas obliger un d'un
match et direct je trouve la partie
vraiment étrange
après c'est difficile pour l'afrique
tourache 8 a du sens dans l'absolu c'est
que c'est quand tu fais ton truc avec
damas schiste tu peux entrer la dame et
après tu attends pour passer sur ses
huit un jour si besoin
oui dans l'absolu elle est mis en fuite
dans achète à pour repasser sur s'est
vite faudra quand même le l'autorisation
de cyril hanouna du alors on fait comme
on peut non mais de toute façon c'est
bizarre d'avoir passé la tour sur la
septième pour allons à vii pour après
fairways set to write pouvoir retourner
c'est pas marrant mais qui craque
si claire des banques à part 4 h 3 ça
c'est une bonne question
il faut le faire que si samat parce que
lorsqu en fait tu te peut-être à kiev 0
h 2 et ça peut être même une faiblesse à
long terme et a pas de quartier pour
déloger le site à 20 kg qui vient g4 ça
pourrait faire péter la position mais en
transgression de la dame désolé j'ai
encore plus j'avais vraiment pas vu que
la dame courrier dernier les tarifs 6 e
manon et que c'est vous qu'on attend des
jeux vraiment à 6 es3 à es7 paraissent
vraiment superflu au moins un des deux
ouais je suis assez content kairouan il
se passe quoi est ce qu est ce qu on est
près de l'action qui est prise prise
d'un match croix dommage de pardon car
et les ce2 peut-être c25 toute part nous
sommes obligés tour à schwyz et la bête
comme l'aja aurait pu de jeux de tirage
suite au coude avant non comme le foot
et en deux sets mais d'un autre côté ça
va garder le ranger huit tarifs
moi mais ouais mais foulée 5 c'est une
bonne idée donc leroy f 7 est bien pour
tenir aussi c'est vrai aussi à temps
est-ce qu'il a joué il ya eu à 4 il m'a
empêché foulée 5 1 4 alors à temps alors
dit claque c'était gagnant après h3 on
va regarder pourquoi son pied dans glace
et c'est du concret donc plus on prend
fou prenait 4 juste c'était gagné en
deux coups ouais si on prend et 23h 3m
attend à agen ouais mais bon pourquoi
pas un trou en fait si le mec parce
qu'il faut expliquer aux gens c'est que
si le mec peut pas prendre à ces tapis
sont rangées de ça va être très très
fort oui parce que juste pour montrer
notre genre si on fait fou prend
maintenant
puis on prend puis on prend droit prend
je dis ok y'a pas d'un machin maths je
suis bien mais on fait un match hyper
majd hermach et en deuxième est-ce que
bientôt être trois classes et allemand
moins cher trop non mais c'est fois je
crois vraiment et dans cette compétition
là on a pas on a justement plutôt
encenser les joueurs en disant que ça
joue assez bien mais je crois
honnêtement que cette partie d'un niveau
assez pâle mathieu et attends j'ai
compris à 4 c'est pour joe kals et de
empêcher trouvé ça oui ça oui ça c'était
sûr mais je rate et h3 pour maxime avec
il a pris 30 secondes pleines pour jouer
tourache 8,1 et un jeu trois cavaliers
dans mes matches ne s'est pas joint sa
petite fille en fait si tu fais âgées au
prochain de façon tu es content non tu
vas jouer et sur g h i tu vois qu'il
faut prendre avec 81 points à 3 non mais
en plus maintenant ça marche plus
puisque comme un noyé les ans le 2 h 3
tue pas plus fou prend un f4
intermédiaires je prends et je reprends
du cavalier je suis même mieux que je
partage 2 dans le c7 je suis gagnant
c'est très étonnant bas que cette partie
on refait un petit tour des stades
ouais moi je préfère sur les normes
ouais pareil en est plutôt petit
avantage noir maintenant
ouais mais il va la perdre les bonnes
les bonnes vannes a perdu seul annonce
donc il va falloir mettre les poings
ailleurs ici ça va ça devient nul on
c'est chaud mais ça va il n'y a pas
derrière elle un problème est ici alors
attends c'est pas la bonne position
ok ça c'est bien c'est bien ça a bien
avancé mais ça avance et dangereux
positivement sas à avancer positivement
donc en gros il va y avoir une défaite
de l'evole une nulle au 3éme axe il faut
vraiment qu'ils gagnent on est mieux
dans le match
alors ça je comprends pas du tout ce qu
on est mieux dans le match mais cette
partie là entre maxime vachier lagrave
et hikaru nakamura mathieu elle et elle
est quand même assez indécise
c'est quoi ce coup et je comprends rien
il a quand même fait il avait la tour en
huitièmes il a fait tous rêvent sept
tours à vii pour la passe et puis l'ami
laurent f 16 pour refaire tourache 8 tu
l'as fait damas six dames f6 et a6 ça
mathieu ce sont les sept derniers coups
de maxime et remet la touriste écouté
hier il ya de l'eau dans le gaz il ya un
problème à mon dos les noms mais il va
madame h 8 mai un message est compris
mais je leur parle à qui joue quand même
parce qu'il aurait dû faire en 4 où il
vient de le faire en 10 c'est un film à
la ccaf 3 tu lui donnes un exercice
c'est le trouve en une seconde
voyage 3 ha je crois qu'il a raté c'est
vrai qu'ils habiteront il a 30 secondes
pour jouer alors que c'était un coup
simplissime tu donnes ce qu'on appelle
un puzzle rush surtout à ce point comme
je pense car je crois il doit vraiment
une ou deux secondes après ils peuvent
aider toujours bien mais juste pourquoi
pourquoi tant de mains tant de haine
je pense qu'il va faire nul nul au gain
conduit dans le chat qui doit être crevé
oui clairement là pour moi c'est de la
fatigue de pour les deux joueurs
d'ailleurs pas que pour maxime pour
hikaru aussi mais maxi mis à part
l'ouverture où il connaît rien mais ça
on a l'habitude cinq ans et rien pour
son niveau et surtout qui j'ai échangé
de la thuringe comme tient à préciser
il a bien joué après g5
on n'y avait pas pensé en fait qu'est
sait si c'est pour jouer pour lui
sans blâmer pas compris nous a laissé
six il veut y jouer vraiment pour le
bien mais là il se met dans le côté
stratégique manoeuvre il a été bon mais
là dans le côté tactique connaissant
maxime qui est un des meilleurs
tacticiens
tout comme age 3 vraiment c'est une
tâche est lourde à 9,6 dame insiste je
rigole bien de faire tout rage cet
ouvrage cet ouvrage suite watch six
tours h 7 av
il trouve pas les principaux c'est
celle-là haute voltige
alors peut-être maintenant qu'il attend
simplement de voir ce qui se passe sur
les autres partis et voir si je dois
jouer entre nous le dernier chic et
c'est peut-être le plus important
peut-être moi j'aime bien ce que font
les blancs après j'aurai quand même
s'ils foutent pas avoir doublé un peu
plus tôt sur la colonne pour éviter un
os 6
mais aussi se perdent rien qu'ils ont
ici je pense qu'on peut prendre et
prendre angers 5 taureaux cinq échecs
auxquels sens je sais pas non il ya toi
même ça c'est quand même mieux tour h 50
jeu le jeu tour elf un échec très dur je
vois que tu vas voir un club moins un
mouvement social
non et non avec dur alors qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait dans la partie graphique
chypre où la g prend h4 j'adore pour les
blancs
ouais ce but on va perdre cinq tours eu
un rush 5 à évoluer le système emcs est
prise et or au 5e tour descartes je
pense c'est l'idée tourer qu'elle
pourrait lancer comme nom moi c'est
gagner en hauteur des victimes qui a dit
sa maxime qui a fait nul d'accord ok moi
il a quand même raté un gain est clair
donc en fait la pulsion clé faudrait
voir so par hasard s'il n'est pas
l'impression aniche aux trois alors
attends mathieu ce qu'on va faire c'est
juste vous donner une petite seconde je
change des caméras changer de caméra et
on va rester sur nana peut-être un petit
peu
voilà j'ai laissé qu'un peu sur mes
joues pour 5 il faut qu'elle double tour
3 d'ailleurs pour empêcher la tourner
mené entre autres il faut taper sur ce
point
de toutes ses forces pour moi c'est
proche de gagnant humana qui n'est pas
la personne la mieux cadré du monde sur
la caméra désolé on peut pas voir
beaucoup mieux sa faute elle nourrit au
total attend va mettre son nom se
prononce donc l ajout rs qu'on a proposé
je pense tour suite ou re tour s'est
vite c'est peut-être main pour jouer au
taureau 1 tour 16 6 et tour des quatre
thèmes pas tour descartes pour un poids
de 80 sagan ce que tu aurais dit elle
5-2 gagne tout
je pense et mieux d'attaquer le pubic
itunes et du coup tour celui de être
plus malins à l'idée de taureaux un
torse 6 mais je pense que tour à
shanghai droit j'ai six tours 1
attenton prend 1,6 marche peut-être ef
cet échec
pourquoi ce qui est beau aux échecs
c'est que des fois un pied au cul suffit
gagner il faut dire quand même parce que
quand ils arrivent au bout ça peut se
transforme en dame 1 donc là on peut
dire en a qu'un point de plus et rien
mais en fait non c'est tout surtout
qu'ils restent très peu de pièces donc
avoir un avantage d'un pion au tout
début ça peut être pas si grave
mais en fin de partie c'est juste
décisif alors on nous dit
que maxime des soins alors je trouve pas
au premier échiquier la partie la 8 nuls
une victoire c'est un excellent résultat
mathieu ouais ouais non c'est très bien
mais juste il a raté un gain après
peut-être qu'à la fin il y avait juste
rien à faire les blancs s'étaient
regroupés visuellement c'est beau mais
peut-être quelques attaques mais oui h3
à moins qu'on ait raté un truc me
l'avait vérifié avec le petit module ça
avait l'air d'être gagnant ainsi
facilement alors on peut faire juste un
petit tour des stades pour ça on va
laisser la phase où j'ai prêté leur nom
et sa patte en vingt six écoles
maternelles fauqué prendre tour faut
prendre tout ce matériel égal mais on
est peut-être un peu basses pressions
venant pas sûr qu'on ait besoin de
menaces cachées 3 sa peine en mars
salaires baissent alors on est peut-être
un poil suppression maintenant il a fait
tomber 5
je comprends pas aaron hill et et à quel
point il ya prise ici mais qui va-t-on
en trois il est quand même pièce ou non
pendant que ça vient ça leur donne ça
doit aller ou pire il va avoir une
finale qui ont moins faut juste qu'il
fasse gaffe autant à nishi c'est pas là
il a fait tour c'est cette d'accord donc
il va faire un nul à l'accueil des
quêtes ok cool donc çà çà çà çà fait ça
bon et du coup les vols c'est quand même
important
ça doit tenir encore militaires et les
moins devient un cru f3c 6 peut-être
contre jeu en elle quelque 1,4 pour la
caisse des six il est moins bien ça sent
le nul des fouets 3 500 matches pour une
fois il faut absolument que malaga lyon
va se rassurer au sein de bien jouer
elle a six minutes comptent trois années
mais avant j'ai peur que le que le petit
loupé de maxime nous coûte cher mathieu
on sait que dans ces matches accrochés
pas rater d'occase et un rognon qui
était quand même beaucoup mieux d'en
manger trois dames âgées quatre
d'ailleurs visiblement schwaller n'avait
mini module vite fait ils pouvaient au
rêve des quatre qui était le coup
logique stratégiquement face il y avait
peut-être dame gkp tout de suite qui
était vraiment fort donc tours 5
c'est à irin à crouch ou crush c'est pas
que l'on prononcé de jouer sur sa
américaine pas une proposition nul alors
attends ça vient d'où des quatre jouer
nulle non pas du tout des développeurs
c'est les vagues qui a proposé nul à
messi passeur qui sommeille en fait si
tu fais h trois balles
je te fais un petit coup d'oeil 3 je
termine pour un câble en d6 si j'arrive
à échanger à combes et je vais me
rapprocher de l'égalité mais juste
est-ce que je vais y arriver c'est pas
ça cette passion à 1000 pensant ça
serait bien que mais fabien nous qui va
pas accepter un toit avec le match le
match parce que bon viry on la dirait
que c'est très bien je qui est des
cathos personnes en février pour
lesquelles je vous prends way et il faut
s'attaquer qu'aux et tu peux pas prendre
et l'hôte écho aussi les lieux c'est
génial on sent que vous aurez donc ça va
faire nul et nul est en fait la
proposition de l'even s'étira caruana
lien on joue tout sur six si votre
joueuses sur la nuit lire in ah tiens là
nul vous fait match nul et c'est dans
votre intérêt et 6e nana gagne ça le
faire les joueurs cocasse du cou qui
peuvent à faire la différence dans ce
match tours à chaque roi g7 faut pas se
prendre au point de seesmic et je viens
de comprendre et l'idée c'est que si
maintenant on fait tout un cinq tours
des cartons contre jeu arrive ouais tu
en france et 5 tromperie stopperont s4c
cet échec ça j'ai l'impression que ça
guen je suis pas sûr autant j'ai trois
pages et 3 roues f4 ça va gagner parce
qu'on avait car bkv cap des cinq ans va
se créer un pion passé non c'est
complètement gagnant bekkat des 5
c'est 5 ou prise à 6 avant que 6 6 s'est
bien passé
ça va enfin autant faim largement ça va
bien se passer mais tu viens donc pour
lacombe poux on a répondu c'était très
bien de mettre aniche au noir parce que
d'aude à illescas mal préparé et donc
avec des noirs contre sony en plus ça
fait une très bonne partie et dialysés
je pense à un très bon choix quand
crosby la preuve technique est pour
l'instant la domine complètement
pour l'instant on en est loin d'être
content après un côté paid content la
fin mais pour l'instant le monde l'a
fait roi h5 j'aime bien aura juste un
quotidien fait gaffe à tour d2
non c'est pas mal ce temps des deux rois
prend fin jeudi au 2e tour à tour 5
wahou tous à 8 ok mais ça c et ku d'ordi
et si l'autre voie de prendre
oui mais j'ai cinq attend faut encore
trouver wife 7 g 6 3 6 j'ai cette force
et ça c'est ok tu peux le prendre mais
même temps je dois je peux enfin changé
et c'est peut-être même et noir qui pour
tu vas faire tour 5 y aller chercher la
demande d'un ton jeu saint georges au
secret mais auquel à tour t3 la même
idée mais ça tu peux le prendre avec les
blancs pas je peux comprendre que tu
rates ça non mais il reprend la chance
d'agir c'est possible qu'il faut juste
comprendre métro et qui sans doute
perdant avec g5 tourache un drapeau
prochain d'ailleurs est-ce que tout
rachat est pas un coup de ménage peut
suffire aux harrachis saint trop atteint
l'asie pourquoi juste pour expliquer un
truc c'est que si on commence par tour
ces 8es à tort qu'on réussisse c'est là
toute la difficulté de voir le tour
s'est vite c'est qu'il faut commencer
par te rage 3 puis faire pour s'éviter
comprendre que j'ai cinq est pas un
problème c'est quand même dur mais a
battu justement regarde regarde tu auras
chanteur s'est vite voilà le bien aussi
c'est pas après tout c'est ce que ouais
véraison leeuwen va perdre quelqu'un
manager
non il n'a jamais été aussi c'est très
très chaud il ya les deux un passé
on n'en sait rien qui est bien c'est pas
c'est hyper compliqué pour ces trois
joueurs
j'aime bien parce que cif et au point 4
prises prix
c'est cette fausse et 8b cinq tours b 4
j'avais passé 5
je ne veux pas m'arrêter mais méritait
peut-être une sorte de forteresse ce que
roy f6 cannes à temps des cinq tours
david
ok ok donc ça devrait faire mais aussi
pousse son pion il a fait quoi georges
tron ont bien joué et bien joué
senator aniche qui a plus de temps mais
non mais ça c'est juste facile mouais
mais je sais combien de temps
non non mais le dernier chic islamabad
est vraiment là que ça va jouer c'est
sûr ça peut faire quatre nuls ce match
qui serait complet saveurs nul avec un
beauf ait d'ailleurs
ouais elle avait quelques regrets quand
même pour la poule avec trois positions
supérieures dont une où on aurait pu
perdre ma à rognan et maxime mal et les
regrets sont quand même plus du côté de
maxime qui lui avait vraiment le coup
gagnant mathieu annan a aussi à la
finale aller jusqu'à m mais en fait
peut-être que ça encore gagnante on a eu
trois hommes elana finale gagnante
jean-maxime en fait ils trouvent le coup
ces abandons h3c c'est quasiment abandon
il a vraiment coûts qui tua nana c'est
quand même une finale techniques
difficiles torrent 3 c'est peut-être
gagnante racines hockey tour des seins
alors attend une nouvelle proposition du
je vais aller voir ou alémaniques anice
saussez aérien ok très bien
oui oui j'ai un petit point me
capillaire façon ça va pas durer
ouais donc là il ya une nulle d'après
leurs 10 mai au caire honnêtement ou
moqués de croyant une rage et la clape à
trouver goethe et annoncé qu'elle allait
faire ça
donc là on a dit on et les quoi on
n'existera chambre jeudi tout juste 5 de
gym pour agen là nul était très jolie
marie fantastique c'est beau c'est beau
les échecs quand c'est bien jolie belge
et 5 et regardez la différence des plans
toujours la comparaison plus yacé
matériel égal mais lui flambé cette île
et comme beaucoup moins fort que le
plomb g4 qui est à 4 càs d'eau dames et
cas personne devant lui
il a juste fait retour h1 pour pas se
prendre de m'attendre parce qu'alors
bref cette menace matin
tels sont les deux coups candidats cgeci
c'est tout rachat non sinon watch 5 3 à
4 situe peut avoir envie de faire ça ça
et sa sortie et angers 1 ça doit aimer
c'est à dire çà doit gagner aussi de ce
que tu vas faire ça tu me l'as g7 ça va
bien se passer un art mais non à rognan
ou pas après quoi tout est en danger
fureter show furtif
bon je trouve ces huit tours à six tours
à 3 on va on va rester sur un mur nana
parce qu'on a déjà regardé mathieu
histoire de voir la fin des années et on
filera moite et intuitivement giteau
rachetant mais c'est vrai que ce projet
quatre ce que je venais ctte mentionné
c'est peut-être le plus humain en fait
ce que cache ton roi et après tu dis ok
m'ont plongé il est beaucoup plus fort
que et du coup ma tour cantat va passer
sur la colonne h ce sera ça fera plus
mal wen en faut aussi pour moi ça aurait
pas été ensuite il faire j'aurais pensé
que je regardais la même stratégie de
couverture et que et que je poussais
franchement oui mais trop peur de se
faire un hacking way
après oui c'est avec la peur peut-être
que je me serais je serai planté aussi
d'ailleurs est ce qu a mené spies 5e
c'est pas que ça son idée leur tombait
4,5 ce qu'elle veut pas finir la partie
comme ça et or cet heureux wintour sept
matches bon je sais pas ce qu'il m'est
impossible c'est bien la nasa non non
c'est possible et surtout rage 3 l'art
watch et quatre non c'est bien jouer
mathieu quand même nom mais tant mieux
c'est que je propose c'est fait c'est
bien jouer mathieu nana qui mais qui met
une grosse pression et c'est une partie
importante ici main pour les partenaires
elle a perdu tout son avantage autant
[Musique]
mathieu qui connaît sa nana le dire au
pin side linge coloniale et george hill
peut-être un peu trop bien mathieu non
attention c'est très attention prochaine
fois on le dira a démonté grande île
connaît très bien les faiseurs
j'entraîne une joueuse de l'équipe
nationale j'ai donc vu des dossiers mais
cela ne nous regarde pas à tyr
ok roi g4 ça tombe bien on y allait pour
tour d un thème simplement les là c'est
pas si bête elle empêche tout rachat
ainsi à fait tord âge de sa dépense faut
qu'elle fasse ou rage de vannes auray il
ya aussi l'idée f5 paris match c'est
dans le sens où votre pion prend ses
échecs mais je pense que si j'ai bien je
fais le tour des 1
pourtant ces trois paroles ou tomber un
d'ailleurs j'ai pas vu maintenant que tu
es sur la bonne page iturbe un qui est
très fort pour ceux qui croient
s'asseyant autour des seins à l'air de
gagner alors attendre admettons qu'elle
fasse tourache deux tours d un tour
c'est cette tour des six tours sète
tours ce sont les 5 es là tu es con
l'organisme quand tu commences à
défendre tes pions et tincu ion plus est
mais bon faut encore là finira mathieu
la tête descendue à 40 selon oui 40
secondes pour rire une accroche un petit
juste furtif
voilà j'ai peur à cette position me fait
super peur parce que ils ont deux
minutes chacun mais c'est des finances
bull 1 c'est hyper chaud ouais mais je
suis je suis très confiant parce que
quand tu y mets de pioncer 7 ce qui est
bien c'est que pour ces cinq menace par
la prise parce qu'avec à value8 donc
temps de faire moins 3,8 bien joué bien
vos gueules solide et que je regardais
les échecs en tête y avait pas de réseau
nous mettons ces jeux pour ses de ses
chaussures ses 80 d'un tournoi batwing
je montre mes h3 et tourbe et un ca et
tour ici fou bessette et tu peut plus
empêcher ces 8es sa venue le tour de
france et celle qui est 8 c'est celle là
et c'est mieux
là il a joué irina a joué alors green a
joué tour ces trois comme tu le comme tu
es tombé à l'eau
c'est quoi alors de cool pour créer un
touriste et saito un chien peut-être
sale tour à chaud ça c'est très très
près puisque pour pour mettre la tour
sur mes matches on va rester sur le
direct à la ve tour h en direct
ouais mais froissé croit g7 ouais non
non c'est bien en fait moi j'essaie de
tout repère et gentillesse et ton prend
ses quatre tours achète suite au premier
set ça al'air salaires gagnant mais bon
y'a qui ont pas assez c'est maintenant
il ya un peu trop je m'apprête à drouot
s'est chargé
6 3 et 5 pour m6 et mater un bar au hc
sierre 4 mai mais mon lait à comprendre
bessette et dès que la bougie tournoi où
six personnes qui va arriver le 6e tour
sénateurs progressistes fade et mama tu
serais peut être ça la fin de partie oui
alors tout reprend 17 sait de quoi jouer
là pour nana mois elle a le droit de
faire tout recettes d'ailleurs qui
viennent tout de suite stratégiquement
donc non pas saigner un imparable
prendre l'option b quand même ça veulent
en venir
franchement je pense que tour 7-6 pense
qu'un peu de tours cerner la mama tu
m'as mes tours b cette tourbe et 6
[Musique]
passes en 13 27 mai à l'espace jeune
torcéen émanant de jeter un doute
j'espère pas facile à jouer un tour à 4
serait peut-être le coup ici ou tomber
dans l'es4 un tour deux tournages de
maths c'est pas dur à voir un an mais
non mais non mais c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle sa vie dit qu'il fallait
prendre bessette mathieu ça gagne encore
tour 5 je pense je sais mais avoue
qu'avec le pion bessette en moi t'es
qu'un pu rassurer non à la rater ma
tante 3 il met sa santé qu'il fallait
prendre ce lyon tu prends le pion mais
c'est surtout pas jouer roi f5 est
empreint f4 mais on est là on est
d'accord que quand t'as pas vu les trucs
de matour prend bessette était mille
fois plus fort mais je comprends pas en
fait pourquoi ne pas prendre un pion
tour des six la tour des 6 3 6 3 et 6 3
et 5 tours 17 g 6 allée wife cette
chance d'être le plus logique pour un
échec-avant - la case aussi ce jeu des
joueurs au f5 et encore une fois comparé
ces matériels égal mais les pions noirs
et ils se poussent tellement plus
difficilement sont peu ils sont poussifs
tout enfin j'ai peur encore oui l'autre
côté non mais c'est la passion qu'on a
dit plus ou moins maintenant il a mis la
tour en a sept îles a vu tour à 8 mai
rue du contour c5 c'est quoi
dames vous prendrez donc paris vii ou
finaux donc du coup d'armes du coup tu
peux peut-être en profiter pour jouer un
coup d'abord tu es obligé de faire
d'hommes ce qui m'a inscrit mais c'est
au noir de vrais trésors c'est ça qui
menace rien ça je dansais ce qu'il a
fait un bon match on finit l'autre
partie ont fait ouais je laisserais bien
jaune la peugeot n 5 bat déjà nana gagne
et après on en parle parce que youri tu
vas à l'élève 5 f 5 à 6 tours des huit
matchs pour ces sept salles et c'est
bien aussi mais vues sur ces derniers
travailleurs honnêtement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui et f5
là c'est fini là c'est finir f6 et tour
ses huit le stress saint mathieu ouais
ouais bah normalement ça va menacer mate
un âne en as une très bonne chose ou pas
un peu excentrique elle joue très bien
mme anna juste évidemment et m6 1 tu
montes trois villes ya eu 6
alors il refera elle refrain mais chaque
elle va faire des échecs de partout
ouais tu passes par le sein et qui après
tu fais roi des 5 et moi je serais parti
11 des quatre oui c'est ça non mais tu
vas ans et 5 5
ouais pareil trois des cinq tours d un
roi c5 attentif aux pacanes le manche
faux-pas tiennent le manche faut pas
qu'elles ne mangent mathieu si elle
mange le pion rate en c1 mais l'autre ou
qu'elle fasse tourner un tempo qu'est ce
qu'elle fait joue juste tour d un tempo
et tente c'est ton seul piège
ces noyades toro 8 sinon il ya toujours
eu 8 et g cet échec et c'est fini tour à
tour ces huit pour compte et en mettant
des mots peut-être re4 tournoi des iv
avec les blanches quand je préférais la
c3 que ces cinq par principe toute bête
de l'autre côté du pian normalement
l'autre te fait roi des saints qui fait
autour d un thème commun pour te dire ok
on joue tous tels poêles français 4 et à
l'oubli le truc mais là elle réfléchit à
les tontons ton nom c'est 3 bombe à la
tour tout retour ces 8es g7
c'est fini tout de suite pour ces jeux
j'essaie tout de suite je pense était
juste
être bref 7.83 peut-on apprendre 8 et g
8 dames et ça ça va bien se passer mais
elle réfléchit voilà une minute vingt
wells à celle plus rapide en fait ça
gagne aussi ça à tout jouer sur les
bonnes
c'est bien qu'elle n'ait pas tenté de
piège quand même aller ne fait pas et
cette voix là c'était bien là d'un crs
c'est un bon ça c'est une gueule ça ces
nanas qui prend le point a et les bonnes
c'est une culture un second set mais
c'est nul mais il va jouer mais c'est
vrai c'est une forteresse
ces forteresses gens fous décès à 3 g 4
il ya zéro idée en fait on les a
complètement dominé ce que maxime était
gagnant les veines était beaucoup mieux
dans l'ouverture alors attendons à
récupérer les vannes justement quand on
parle du loup quand tu parles du lion
gkp delajoux est ce que j'ai dit tu en
fais tu vas admettre que je fouille 8 où
tu vas tendance était au bout d'un
moment tu vas échanges et j'ai conduit
il ya juste pas d'idée faut juste pas
perdre son fou à ce serait fou là ce
serait une énorme victoire pour l'équipe
européenne mathieu non mais vraiment
zéro idée parce qu'en plus le pion le
pion le plan des normes surface blanche
donc on ne peut toujours les attaques
avec d'autres fous donc le roi peut pas
faire le tour de l'échiquier
voilà je remets à gauche le le score du
match nul de maxime nul de geri victoire
de na na hey c'était le plan match qu'on
avait ciblé avec un coach quand
exactement
exactement - tout était annonce est est
très bon et très bonne compo aniche qui
nous a pas fait perdre du tout avec les
noirs et nana qu'elle fait le job
on sera pas encore qualifié jours à g4 y
avoir trois échecs à le voir mais au
passage c'était quand même court d'abord
un chiffrage ce g5 va être joué à six
chiffres 3 et 4 des tum l'attaquent
parce qu'on fait si tu échanges les
pions c'est vraiment nul facile oui roi
fou contre roye tour s'annonce aussi un
pion girouard faucon trois tours déjà
c'est simplissime mais alors avec un
pion allez faut que les bonnes finissent
le taf maintenant temps qu'il faut et
strauss était juste votre impôt l'aïd al
adha petit prénommé caronna on va aller
on va aller sur sur la cam avec fabi et
on va mettre les bonnes
sa vie est complètement déprimée avec
fabi de ce côté-là fabrique à l'air
déprimé ray c'est la déprime à d'à côté
côté américain la veille non ils sont
pas encore éliminés quand même ça nous
promet en plus ils ont parenti l'on n'a
pas une non roger à vue oui ainsi
permanent parce que avec un fou de cases
blanches tu peux jamais avancé 3 et dès
qu'ils joueront deux frères âgés de ça
fait quand même un inconnu dans les
écoles travaillé à l'entraînement teint
est par contre j'aurais jamais fait ça
c'est sans doute très fort c'est bien
joué quand même de l'évent très bouge de
partout on a les deux c'est un athlète
roger de donc dès que le roi passons et
de l'idc 3g deux mais trois membres f3
ouais ouais bien joué aussi une enquête
vous voyez ce système c'est assez
intéressant de vous le montrer
le roi j'ai un saut de cannes blanches
en fait seul le roi passe pas donc là
moi je ne prendrai pas le pion je
repartirai parce que prison break 3 3 et
des toits il est un peu dans un match 5
3 g iii roi de france par angers 1
reprendrait pas je pense
après d'accord non croyants trois
menaces pas ma tante c'est ça la chance
je vais te faire ton g45 est vraiment
jamais mater ce qu'il faut quand même
essayer pour fast rester c'est de
sauvegarder un pion ouais il faut
regarder - qui ont acheté un backup et
après je t'aime moi j'ai quatre pour
empêcher rouages et h5 mais maintenant
elle est là on y croit 1 5 mois très
bien airways et brive 5 et j'avais peur
tu comprends c'est que j'avais peur que
le valais va amener son curateur fin il
va amener son qu il va faire comme s'ils
allaient d'annexion quoi est-ce que je
suis ici dit moi j'avais juste peur son
antre commence en mai soit voilà il
n'eut c'est fini mathieu victoire de
l'équipe pour elle
faby dégoûté mais il est tombé sur plus
fort que lui à wichita mille coudées
désolé je suis à la maison sauf hélas il
est tombé sur sur un les bonds
impressionnants mathieu et l'équipe
l'équipe d'europe mathieu t-il en bord
de émirats et demi dans ce match décisif
et maintenant on a notre destin entre
les mains pour aller au final est-ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on fait est ce
qu'on va voir les autres l'autre match
on s'en fout ou par curiosité mais après
il reste plus qu'une partie de toute
façon ça a l'air bien maintenant et qui
vient de se terminer nous permettre les
scores des autres matchs déjà mathieu
pour commencer alors la chine qui a
encore gagné face à ses yeux ou encore
un à la noix avec ceux qui marquent
encore donc la chine tranquille et la
russie qui a fait match nul contre le
reste du monde simplement et donc au
classement mathieu ça va être sadr est
en train d'être mises à jour
donc la chine qui caracole en tête avec
17 points l'impressionnant quand même la
chine
ouais on a réussi à peine six points
j'ai envie de dire nombreux vêtements
états unis décevant mais
on savait qu'ils avaient imprimé chic et
féminin dans l'équipe nationale
américaine ça fait des années des années
qu'elle a pas quelque chose chez les
femmes oui et la russie qui ont même
compétition mixte
tu as beau avoir les meilleurs devant si
tu perds au dernier c'est ce qui leur
arrivait face à l'europe aujourd'hui
après tous été dominé sur les échiquiers
masculin phare mixte aussi 17 sur 17
possibles sur dix huit noms alors 18
watan ont peur ils ont fait un match nul
et je sais plus contre qui non elle a
fait combien de points dont je ne sais
pas ouais maxima qui à vrai qu'il ya un
peu vendanges et la non c'est vrai qu'on
les a vraiment si tu regardes le
scénario du match on les a vraiment
dominé 1
c'est vraiment une victoire méritée mais
il faut encore battre l'équipe du reste
du monde pour irina s'appelle mauvaise
joueuse un peu les joues en 2007 j'avais
fait nul mais mais c'est un cran en
dessous que oui fans qui mais ajuste de
mondovi huazhong écharpe du monde et
d'ailleurs je sais pas si tu l'as dis
danger pas écouté tous à vos string mais
est ce que tu sais qui riina et le co
lead
oui je sais on a parlé peut-être pas
aller en plus elle n'est pas un
mégaphone les attend ce qu'il sait
d'autre d'autres joueurs avec un
vraiment en dessous pour moi oui elle
est moins forte
j'ai joué beaucoup de joueuses ben jerry
finn tournoi fermé où il avait habité
plein de choses étranges et c'est assez
bizarre
enfermé à la roche sur yon j'avais joli
bidon le tournoi derrière avec quels
résultats
on a fait nul laisse tes mains est la
plus forte des joueurs c'était stéphane
aubin en plus en 2007 et est très forte
je vais gagner
irina j'avais fait nul et là entre
inhumé plus faible c'était au ska
j'allais perdre et on dit que sur le
stream officiel maxime a dit qu'il
trouvait le nul parce que 2,2 ça allait
ouais parce qu'ils considèrent que la
chine va va faire le taf on apprécie
voit le h3 il le fait aussi à baru faut
arrêter mais après ça peut expliquer
quelques choix étrange aussi un
1 est ce qu'on sait quand est-ce que ça
va reprendre à 17 heures d'accord c'est
une belle pause nous raconter des
histoires mathieu jean raconte jean
raconte on peut regarder comme les
parties des autres matchs que tu t'en
fous complet non mais alors ce que tu
peux faire éventuellement c'est nous
dire ce qui peut y voir sympa pour moi
je regarde mon côté hu est vite fait
attends moi j'écris quand vas tu peux
regarder vite fait de son côté sur une
victoire ou quoi pour mes gars qui selon
moi je vais passer le le temps à
chercher des pseudo et donc c'est une
victoire sympa une partie sympa
est ce qu'on sait qu'il va jouer contre
le reste du monde dit kai fu coué
couthenans les compositions sont donnés
une demi-heure avant donc nous le temps
que que les arbitres les accepte etc
on devrait les avoir vert - 20 - car en
tout cas c'est quand même super plaisir
cette victoire mathieu et du coup ce qui
contredit le dernier match reste du
monde moi et donc ils sont quand même
probable c'est l'équipe supposée être la
plus faible tout cas ça nous offrirait
une super finale demain 16h les gars si
si vous voulez suivre donc on sait pas
encore qui affrontera la chine mais il
est probable qu'ils aient un un match
chine chine europe demain 16 heures donc
la partie de yum pour la regarder il a
gagné très très facile
c'est au fond il va y avoir une partie
amusante à regarder
c'était du grand n'importe quoi qui
pourrait mettre un petit rappel pour
demain va écoute c'est vrai que ce sera
ce sera une belle finale
surtout si l europe pour nous est ce que
tu penses qu'on aurait des chances
contre la chine en finale en sachant
qu'en cas de match nul ce qui gagnerait
1 puisqu'il aurait il aurait terminé
premier à une fouille oui oui bien sûr
parce que la réunion peut battre à mains
nues
en théorie on est meilleurs aux 2 et 3
est donc une limite humain tu mets un
dauda de duda ou un guerrier mage serait
plutôt un dauda pour essayer de gagner
s'il faut absolument gagner
mvl contre ding c'est eux c'est kif kif
mais c'est vrai qu'au 2 et 3 faut faire
un point fr exploit aux 4,2 pas perdre
ça reste quand même difficile de faire
face à willy fans mais meehan amouzou
coudane afghaniser ont le niveau 1
vu le show et la finale je crois d'après
ce que j'ai vu ça en une partie à la
finale je vais je vais vérifier
je crois que c'est un mac mais ça je ne
sais pas qui je mettrais peut-être
années deviennent wafi roger abattu car
la quina etienne on a assez facile tu
veux je te fasse le topo en bottes on
peut regarder que les victoires
peut-être bien un truc marrant non
chacon peuple alors atteint faut que je
retrouve les joueurs ce qui passe et pas
forcément chose aisée de chez est-ce
qu'il faut que je trouve les pseudos
aussi situe alors alors que les rouches
a gelé donc si rouge assez simple déjà
on va démarrer par ça ouais donc en fait
il s'est mis à la carro cannes dans les
derniers tournois et il a un vrai test
sur la nuque émanant principal c'est la
rente d'avancé avec la f3 flow 2 et 1
[Musique]
qu'elle valait e7 qui a aidé 2 qui est
une souligner mais la partie était un
synthé récente et j'ai assez
impressionnant quand même sa partie je
trouve et carrier qui au passage très tu
m'as demandé de tel à qui ma très bonne
impression sur moi ça fait partie de
ceux qui m'ont fait mauvaise impression
la mie câline fait un moment qu'il est
plus au tapin yards en fait on a un vrai
sens que les noiséens premier que le roi
mais en fait si tu m'attaques pas un
jour je te feras h et 3 h est je suis
tranquille tu ou qui menaçait tour h4 et
le h5 et il en veut tu es noir de mines
en fait c'est marrant tu enfin carey qui
n'auraient par think pas une grande
impression
ouais non mais je les trouvais vraiment
décevant et la petite tactique pour
finir très jolie pas un trouble mais
surtout pas me prendre ma fille quatre
ans ferme
enfin heureusement demain très joli bond
l'a rapidement
c'est un partage qui la saga fait une
pièce calme pour faire sa web série que
j'ai 4 sympa ouais g4 est sympa or il ya
dans les autres partis il ya andré keane
basse américaine il s'est pris un piège
assez jolie alors à temps
andré qui s'adresse lui en haïti ni la
jouer il a joué le bonhomme italienne il
a joué en mode jeu t'agresse et regarde
à sacrifier un pion avec g3 donc ils
envoient il a envoyé un pion pour mener
une attaque sur le rangs adverses
surtout en rapide je fonce une bonne
idée après objectivement on a du mal à y
croire à 100% m ouais en rapide c'est
dangereux ouais donc là on a un présente
les noirs sont au pied il pousse des
cinq donc il décide d'y aller
hélas rien derrière la brève asie des
singles en fait ici la qualité d'un gain
qui marche pas mais qui est très joli et
l'art il fallait jouer damage 3 seul
coup et je vous emmerde 4k l'air de en
fait il a l'air de pas il ne comprend
pas ce que fait l'autre et regarde le
piège georges et quatre sur des 314
c'est joli 13 54 attaque la dame et
auront un match tendu une autre apport
du coup ils convergent avec les
cavaliers
voilà c'est joli s'il prend le cavalier
a été l'épreuve de maths 3 2 voilà sinon
il ya rajab aux craintes et meyer qui
est une gaffe
jolie femme partie art et mêlera
dialogue avec les blancs monts d'arrée
mais m un peu décevant
ils ont beaucoup les locaux bah oui bien
sûr c'est normal ils sont forts et
aurait donc il a une carotte kahn
souligne tu touches à 44 ans pour moi
c'est marrant et donc exit donc la dame
du lac où elle est le coup plutôt la
mode ça ça existe deux normalement c'est
pas un système très dangereux parce que
avec le cabba est essentiel de cavaillon
eux deux est ok rien de spécial il va y
avoir une guerre non c'est toujours un
poil mieux pour les blancs mais ça doit
aller point la gaffe
ouais un peu plus loin quand même il va
se prendre une peau de banane enfin un
petit peu bas et c'est vers la fosse 6
aussi triste non quand ils s'arrêtent
ici il a cru qu'il pouvait prendre b2 à
la fin il y accueille des trains non
c'est une guerre juste
va-t-il a cru qu'ils pouvaient
entreprendre mais deux à peseux royal
fuite mais un fourchette
c'est une grosse grosse grosse grosse et
du coup tu fais jamais tu donnes jamais
17 mai du coup ça se regarde même pas
les ondes plutôt une bonne technique ces
jeux un bon c'était pas mais après je
peux je peux aussi comprendre que quand
tu es déjà éliminé de la compétition
s'était déchiré c'est le même problème à
chaque fois on en parle souvent c'est
bien ouais mais alors là pour cette
compétition le petit avantage c'est
qu'il ya quand même toujours des pour le
pour les spectateurs comme les matches
se jouent en même temps en fait ça c'est
un match reste du monde russie il ya
peut-être personne qui le regardaient tu
vois ce que je veux dire c'est sarah
personnes
sauf le message cité russe ou quoi mais
j'ai cité spectateurs que tu as pas d
qui pour quoi évidemment à la rendre
précédente sur regarde europe usa est là
et bien finalement tu regardes europe
reste du monde et usa chine parce que
c'est les matchs en jeu le russe y a
d'la qui va le regarder pour finir on
peut regarder la victoire de la chine
sur la partie new qui a gagné hyper
facile à gagner contre qui a dit ban a
dit ben je pense alors à temps parce
qu'il faut que je le trouve un damon
soit c'est lui et non à celui là
peut-être qu'ils ressemblent en flammes
indique qu'il a été facile pour le prix
un fois qu'il a vu a dit ban
je trouve très charismatique ouais ouais
comme non sourire fait mixa avait
déconcentré la prima de la première fois
que j'ai vu a dit pendant la vie ça va
poser les primes combat propre parti
parce qu'ils pouvaient pas s'empêcher
d'aller d'aller le voir
wailly voyame il ya un peu décevant en
fait ça fait un peu pschitt a dit van
ouais il progresse plus c'est sûr at il
même il a perdu beaucoup de points et on
rien n'arrête les noirs comme ils ont
été faciles c'est choquant pour elle
mais c'est le panda avec les noirs view
en fait tu pouvais deviner tous les
coups de noir pour l'instant hockey à
chaque déjà j'ai un peu seul e mail il
joue pour lui bientôt j'adore il traîne
un vrai ça parce que si d'apprendre
qu'on profite de la structure donc là
j'ai pas compris pourquoi il a pas pris
ces quatre escales drôle c'est que mec
lui a laissé deux coups d'affilée donc
au gouvernement il l'a pris et j'en
retiens deux minutes de plus en plus il
ay la déchire encore complètement
déchiré
d'armes est ridiculement d'emprunt f2
dame jeanne après celle où tu vois
cabinet neckermann grande souvent
surtout dans une partie comme sos après
ça peut paraître être compliqué comme
jeudi l'équipe à l'équipe dames n'a plus
rien à jouer ça peut être un peu
difficile pour pour certains joueurs qui
ont peut-être plus envie de montrer leur
club prépa plus rien à envie de montrer
quoi on peut y avoir aussi un peu de
saint mathieu je disais l'autre chaîne
cnn
je me fais chambrer par la sacem anna on
parlera nadal ce palmarès us open a du
coup de mais quel con paula pour le
match contre le reste du monde
turf hermes estime logique que nulle
père césar nul banuls en cas de victoire
de la chinoise annonce contre le reste
du monde non moi je parlais du match
contre la chine moi je me voyais déjà en
finale là on a conclu reste du monde
nation parle donc on a les blonds on a
les plans au pointu mais maxime grimpe
lui donner des blancs maxime façon on
propose moi le truc c'est que nana je
pense qu'il faut la mettre contre la
chine ce qui en a un style un peu
dérangeante à peut battre tout le monde
donc et bien c'est qu'elle a je sais pas
est ce que tu es du genre à la mettre là
pour la mettre en confiance
outre les dents tu l'a reposé tu joue
demain est ce qu est ce que tu reposes
maxime aussi parce qu'il avait l'air un
peu fatigué depuis un moment et ce qu'il
n'a pas besoin d'être posée et tu prends
le risque la partie ses envies c'est la
finale n'ont battu repose maintenant
pour je vais bien au final
bref un tube ans avale fatigués de jeu
lunaire ou en plus c'est une question
mais les russes et qu'il faut qu'on
gagne non non non non je pompe si on
perd en éliminer un peu aride la chine
et les usa ganil nous ratons non je
pense qu'il faut jouer les matches
après moi je mets duda
tête à la place de l'even peut-être ce
après avoir guéri les noirs encore c'est
ça ouais peut-être les bonnes tu sens un
peu il a quand même beaucoup joué si je
sors leeuwen
tu donnes et noir et gris ce super le
cadeau mais qui est pas si bête ce comme
ça tu donnes des blancs dans tous les
cas de données blain duda et guy les
plus solides avec les noirs aux deux
parce que c'est moi je sortirai dire que
sortir un rognon c'est logique ce qui
jouera demain dans tous les cas
bienvenue intelligent de faire je devins
et est ce qu'on peut faire jouer de gary
webb s'est posé la question et je crois
pas non paris est donc du coup est ce
que tu peux voir la cam de gary ou pas
non il a fait des fois il l'a vu très
furtivement mais il était immédiatement
mais parfois par erreur il la nuit mais
à chaque fois il est un fait rapidement
mettre sur la cnam non en tout cas belle
complète avec ce que c'est une complète
que tu espères revoir l'année prochaine
et qui s'inscrivent dans le dans le
calendrier
est-ce que tu pars du principe qu'il y
aura un confinement dans un an
non non mais même sans confinement moi
je honnêtement je ne suis pas trop pour
beaucoup de temps sur internet que
cannes et de parents à la limite un des
gros gros comme ça je veux dire de
parents on s'est pas mal il faut pas
qu'il y en ait trop enfin faut pas que
les gens oublient que ceux qui aiment
bien de se voir de faire les tournois en
live devant un échiquier de taper sur la
pendule
ça me manque trop c'est pas un truc
comme ça par an ça me va mais faut pas
qu'il faut pas non plus qu'il y en ait
une un par mois atteint alors je pose la
question différemment
du coup on fait le moment un peu des
vagues j'en ai parlé avec romain hier
est ce qu on part du principe que les
olympiades c'est une belle compétition
d'accord donc on veut pas l'enlever pour
moi oui on est d'accord on est d'accord
l'enjeu j'oppose hypothèse par hypothèse
mathieu qui est en train de se dire oui
il va m'amener donc ça ok on le garde on
part de la deuxième hypothèse que la
coupe d'europe par équipes
c'est une belle compétition on est
d'accord d'europe des clubs tu veux dire
coupe d'europe coupe d'europe des
nations c'est une belle compet un sa
masse sur internet
non non la coupe d'europe des nations
quant à toutes les nations qui règnent
la france la norvège a wing j'ai
encaissé un an sur deux à mesure de la
crise d'accor ses deux complices sur la
sont sympas d'accord on est d'accord ou
pas mais je te fais l'hypothèse par
hypothèse est ce qu'on est d'accord
troisième hypothèse que la coupe du
mondela championnat du monde des nations
c'est une compétition absolument est
incompréhensible quand a eu les deux
autres compétitions dont on parle par
après y'a pas que avec l' europe 1 le
machin des nations cette révélation est
d'accord quant à elle isole un quart des
relents sur deux ce championnat du monde
des nations avec dix équipes comme ça
jamais bien marché ce truc pas on s'en
fout en général ok donc on est d'accord
cette confiture un peu entre os que du
coup ce serait pas intéressant de
changer cette championnat du monde des
nations est bon là c'est par cette
compétition là qui est peut-être un peu
plus marrante
pourquoi pas ouais et même ceux qui
étaient dans la même cadence le problème
mais avait justement comme on a déjà les
olympiades est ce que ça même en ré
alain je te dis pas forcément sur
internet mais est ce que cette
compétition l'a finalement elle n'est
pas un peu plus attrayantes en rapide ça
fait quelque chose de différent là déjà
les olympiades les coupes d'europe et
d'amérique
le défaut c'est qu'il ya aussi un truc
est positif est super le monde sait que
nous la ferons trash entraîneur l'équipe
de france féminine depuis 2011
comme on s'y est qualifié une fois mais
il ya un côté ouais si on termine 5ème
désole un perdant 6 qualifie ça a un
truc comme ça mais honnêtement c'est une
commission qui m'a jamais vraiment
intéressé je suis d'accord on incarnait
un peu en trop pourraient peut-être
avoir cette compétition qui pourrait
être en x ou en
mixte et féminin enfin on peut imaginer
plusieurs mais je trouve que c'est
quelque chose aux échecs qui assez sympa
dans les équipes comme ça elle usa
l'europe la chine en rapide ça change un
petit peu ça fait quelques essais un peu
bizarre le côté europe et reste du monde
face à des pays parce que aux olympiades
l'équipe de france il aurait sa chance
aussi c'est pas faux mais d'un autre
côté c'est pour donner un côté un peu
amicale un peu comme la ryder cup sur
internet j'ai vu des gens qui disait ok
mais pourquoi ce tournoi ce concept pour
cobain pourquoi pas faire des olympiades
sur internet ah ouais je suis
complètement d'accord mais je suis
vraiment d'accord en rapide mais bon ça
s'appelle la prod celle ci après non
mais la vraie fait un truc c'est une
sorte de procès s league s'est pas
complètement fou après la prod cette
ligue
on est d'accord toi comme moi mathieu
que moi cette histoire de pouvoir faire
jouer deux étrangers trois étrangers
dans les mains ça m'énerve déjà un c'est
pas trop logique mais plus mais bon moi
j'étais même pour qu'il y ait un truc
des lots quitte à faire une pro che
slick comme ça et faire un truc rigolo
tu mets le moyen et l'eau voyant que du
coup je trouve ça plus rivaux le format
est sûre tout arrêter les dérogations
pour les 2008 2007
oui oui ça faisait des compositions oui
il faudrait miller a vite renoncé mais
c'est un problème
l'armée c'est faisable tu les as en vrai
pour être fort sur internet c'est la
même chose on se rend mieux l'équipe des
laitiers devant un bus on s'entend bien
avec eux normalement au demeurant la
rime canadienne jeter j'adore
l'expression américaine qui dit don't
blame the players blame the game le
traitement par un joueur prend trois ans
au jeu à la règle on n'a rien
j'ai confiance de la règle ils ont
raison on ne peut pas après est-ce que
les compressions par l'équipe intéresse
la majorité des gemmes baisse à des
pompes quelqu'un comme pour à rognan par
exemple jouer pour son pays c'est très
très important et ça se ressent
d'ailleurs dans cette compétition même
pour l'europe un fan jianping bijoux
bien pour l'arménie les jeunes mères
pour l'europe aussi un l'arménie à un
moment ait gagné plusieurs titres et
c'est ils étaient accueillis comme des
stars dans leur pays
je sais pas si les gens sont au courant
c'est que le président sait peut-être
l'ancien président
parlant de révolution en sorte de
révolution je ne sais pas trop et le
président de la fédération des échecs
arménienne était président du pays juste
en fait donc c'est quelque chose de
vraiment important dans leur pays et ils
apprennent les échecs c'est une matière
obligatoire à l'école d'alba ok je
savais pas mais je sais pas qui est
quand même à quelque chose d'assez
d'assez exceptionnel pourquoi ce n'est
pas le drapeau européen
quelques le monde bonne question
alors ça honnêtement j'en ai pas la
réponse mais peut-être parce qu'on joue
comme continent est pas comme union
européenne oui d'accord là dessus
c'était un peu bizarre non qui tue mais
dans la team reste du monde
bah c'est vrai ce duo en fait non plus
des joueurs non sélectionnés dans les
autres teams tout vêtement ouais c'est
ça donc qu'il payera les joueurs
européens moi je moi je serai à gevrey
voilà encore quelques petits trucs qui
m'ont pas forcément super plus j'aurais
bien fait une équipe continent africain
même s'ils sont moins forts pour en
mettant amine ben hassen en mettant en
mettant salam sall et samedi n'ont
jamais eu chaud au coeur ça m'irait
j'aurais plutôt fait une team continent
africain que reste du monde mais bon
voilà après ça m'étonne moi j'aurais
plutôt vu une ultime continent américain
même si ça aurait été la même équipe
plutôt qu elle ça même si tu fais
rentrer qui met peut-être une fille tête
aurait pu avoir
tu vois corrie du pérou on aurait pu
avoir une joue et sud américaines où
j'aurai plutôt fait c'est un film
antartica comme au qatar ouais j'aurais
plutôt fait ça après chine et inde c'est
tellement des pays peuplé que ça peut se
comprendre que c'est aussi d'ailleurs à
la russie s'il ya quelqu'un qui me
remercient pour la dernière draft aux
classes il dit que c'était la plus
lourde saluer ce qu'il a vu celle sur
les candidats parce qu'elles étaient
lourdes aux sig métier il faudrait qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on essaye de se faire
un truc monsieur alain j'ai eu
énormément de bons retours sur 7 mars
sur place truc de fou mais le avec le
truc tordu ou je peux le changer de
thème gamme
non tu peux changer de thème mais à
messieurs refaire trucs tordus
j'ai eu énormément de bons retours ya
plein de voix qui m'ont dit que c'était
passionnant et qu'ils ont vu une
nouvelle facette des échecs grassart
grâce à toi mathieu nay et pourquoi fait
pas une équipe alpha 0 sotchi show digne
héritier montre contre eux ttt stupa
flouzat chu comment il s'appelle ces
gestes ou slim suffisent
c'est une carbonade flamande
ces implants ont souri aux hausses
touchent wallace et ça n'avait cessé
d'émettre partie c'était vraiment
passionnant
je me fais souvent encore adam début des
matchs oui toi j'ai fait une petite
erreur c'est un peu plus long mais la
géométrie aux échecs c'est important ça
se prononce t'offre l'aise on lui dit
bonjour on croit alors il est donc la
prochaine c'est l'annoncé pas un avec
vlad j'aime bien utiliser le mot
normalement avant mais j'ai dit à
breteil normalement ça avec l'abe et
normalement ce sera sur les fusions
kétou pour protéger bien pour bien
protéger son papy comédie histoire
d'être bien tranquille la compo est
tombée alors allez c'est parti
alors moi je les pense du coup à ce que
nul nul nous assure pas encore ça dépend
plus que de l'autre match ouais ça
dépend et ça dépend mais non mais tu vas
tu teamteam continent américain
sa mort est quand même ray plus plus
plus mais après je pensais pour le
marketing ont voulu mettre usa mais je
trouve que c'est un peu un peu dommage
mouais moi honnêtement ça me choque pas
je dis pas que ça me choque plus
j'aurais préféré j'ai une question c'est
tabou de parler de votre main de jeudi
soir
notre nouvelle défaite bah non c'est pas
tabou mais bon on fait avec qui qui nous
fait perdre le match à la fin vous
faites revenir les matières fait jouer à
montréal à la fin et sa perte
m mais la rente c'est fou de la
physionomie du match
ouais 5 0 et on s'est relâché et tu veux
je te trouve un jour de sept lots qui
jouera mieux
non j'ai tu sais faire participer les
gens qui suivent souvent la chaîne c'est
pas très important mais mais c'est sympa
non ces matches là toi tu suis du coup
on voulait la rainbow lost mais je
suivais tellement longtemps
comment vous voulez d'aidé au premier
alors n'allez pas nous dit alors quand
même pas mauvais l'autre baddou d'être
vous bien ouais c'est bien honnêtement
c'est tard pour elle ah oui la
fourchette ses tableaux au dd fait des
petites erreurs qui cote de dd la joie
ouais le prochain plus c'est un conte
double qu'on va jouer contre contre
alexandra ouais j'ai vu non non on peut
faire j'ai trouvé un site bien pour
faire de la belote la coinche frito lay
ouais tu joues à le soir pendant le
confinement moi pas beaucoup une fois
par semaine tu tues avec d'autres
joueurs d'échecs que mathieu bons rails
avec un grain qu'un autre se remettre à
la table il y avait ma zone et sinon
deux joueurs d'échecs mais pas
professionnel mais bon ou 2100 et et un
petit 1400 way et ça joue bien à la
belote
ça joue mieux qu'aux échecs mais même de
ton côté tu pensé me devenu plus fort à
la belote quatre ans non quand même pas
tort aux échalotes
libye libye je pense qu'il est plus fort
à la côte ouais ça me rend fou non mais
on a vraiment beaucoup travaillé
rezé répond quand on joue moi je peux
faire défaut de concentration libye fait
quand même très peu d'erreurs non il est
mille fois qu'il est vraiment concentré
à la pelote
mais on a gagné pas mal de tours dans
l'ensemble j'ai bien j'avais ya
quelqu'un qui m'a posé une question
d'une variante sur la master class ou
mettant les coûts
le par je pensais que c'était entre eux
nous parle de la finale que tu as montré
après quatre des cinq en fait ce que tu
fais c'est que tu vas tu prends pas en
r3 tu vas tu montres ton roi je pense
que je la gagne si c'est bien à pezens
urgente est de dominium échappé par elle
à bouloc c'est pas une blague un dessert
que tu vas venir jouer l'année prochaine
tu viens avec fat veulent changer la
france de belote à cannes
lavoisier qui le fait avec déjà avec
rémy donc tu auras un autre coéquipier
maso mm transit maso il n'est pas assez
sérieux donc je sais pas comment on va
faire
mazeau la couche est très théorique quoi
le système dénonce maso qui aime bien le
tennis aussi des revues que je qu'on
parle de ce point pour une fois il se
trouve qu'il adore le club de tennis où
joue à cannes
enfin il est déjà venu voir jouer notre
tournoi annuel et s'est déplacé de
bordeaux magazine mazet se battirent
base est donc un grand maître français
qui est très bien que la sûreté ni sain
il est quoi il est de 6 je crois qu'ils
étaient 2 si ce n'est celle ci qu au
dessus 15e n'existait que 4,6 peut-être
froid je me rappelle plus exactement les
classements comptent et non j'y connais
rien maintenant ils étaient pas 30 ans
ils étaient 12 31 maso j'ai connu il
était il est et je pense qu'ils étaient
minimum 15 3 et je pense qu'il était
plutôt plutôt de l est et 15 3 44
cascades on me dira s 15,4 gino j'en
sais rien je connais pas le système
quand je dis au pif mais à mais du coup
donc été bon joueur de tennis et qui
viendra te dise aux ailes mais il devait
monter
moi je conseille t 15 3 ans va dès qu'il
devait me passer 15 2 et finalement il a
plus assez de points pourquoi tout cas
qui est un bon joueur de tennis et donc
il ya beaucoup de joueurs d'échecs de
haut niveau qui suivent le tennis lors
pas tout ce qu'ils jouent mais qui
suivent les exploits de rodger federer
on a battu les usa d'ailleurs un qu'un
super match quelqu'un demande s'il y en
a qui viennent d'arriver très très bon
match
maxime meyer fait qu'une nul mais parce
qu'il tend gestion il pensait que nul
c'était bien pour le match aniche solide
et avec les noirs les vols mieux de
l'ouverture qu'après sous pression mais
a bien défendu et une victoire assez
facile en fait stratégique de nanak a
gagné la finale tranquille
ouais beau match et maintenant on va
affronter le reste du monde l'équipe
dont la tête d'affiche et steam ou
radjabov est le joueur le plus connu on
va dire à présent c'est firoud déjà un
gel voire de 16 17 ans encore il a été
comment cette semaine et vidéo d'ébats
eu des très mauvaises partie des très
bonnes en ça oui tu es un garçon qui
peut perdre comme tout le monde le
gagnant 2 tout le monde dit la technique
en finale dans la partie contre les
vannes aronian contre notre notre équipe
a été plus que moyenne alors on a les
appareils n'ont pas encore l'endroit les
avoirs et les 43 ans qui me les affiches
en tout cas moi je veux voir les joueurs
entrent et je peux te dire que tout da
sera titulaire ce alors que je peux te
lâcher
ce qui hélas cette première arrivée là
ça va arriver à 45 en masse d'où
d'ailleurs pour les gens vendent donc
moi ces jeux avec lui en équipe assez
longtemps à bois colombes et jeux pour
notre club en france et on l'a et julian
projet qui est un très sympa c'est un
jeune très sympa qui a un talent pur
pour moi très doué mais qui est un peu
feignant qui à mon avis pas la meilleure
structure autour de lui malheureusement
pour sa progression mais il a quand même
fait quoi des champions du monde de
blitz non les jantes trois doigts
deuxième deuxième avis sur deux il me
semble et genre était le seul qui
pouvait ramener magnus à la fin c'est
lorsqu'on pense à une équipe d'afrique
avec ali amin bassem hicham hamdouchi
estime benkhodja bail que ce serait une
belle équipe après pour cette
compétition là ça semble quand même un
petit peu léger mathieu bas sont une
petite pensée pour hicham qui joue plus
trop hein c'est pas c'est un cadeau un
point bonus de hicham de la grande
époque
willow il aurait embêter beaucoup de
gens oui cham qui a été champion de
france d'ailleurs
il m'a battue l'année 11 après l'aller
gagné un talent est vrai contre
jean-marc degraeve c'était très bizarre
alors j'avais dit terme à johnny alors
il y aura mvl compte radjabov les vannes
comptons firoud cha doo dah contre la
mine basse aime justement dont on
parlait et nana qui est de nouveau têtu
titularisé et qui va jouer contre ça
doit casse sauva moi je lettres
honnêtement je la trouve surévalué cela
passera à 25 pour moi noël bien plus
forte après sur une partie du projet
elle est très bien préparée heureux
quand on a ses positions mais je ne
trouve pas très passante a été bien bien
entraînés dans un moment ça doit
casseurs alors les ouvertures
oui oui mais je tue mais non mais ces
séjours chez par était sous les eaux
jose kazakh à gazon avec américains sont
invités partout et des fois pas trop
trop top une chose comme nana pour moi
est juste plus forte en fait plus de
ghost
ouais mais après les jeux vous quand
même pas mal hein ça doit qu'à savoir
quand elle a ses positions comme tu me
racontes à la 6e position son meilleur
connaisseur français des échecs rien
mais honnêtement c'est c'est pas sûr
c'est pas complètement faux s'est pas
son autre four mais bien dit qu'elle
devrait enfin je suis entraîneur les
guides de france depuis neuf ans donc à
force je les connais un peu tout
friedrich il dit que fil rouge est
devenu connu avec le mag du service
national alors je crois pas non pour moi
il était un peu avant quand même ça fait
déjà un an à mon avis à peu près qu'on
nous en parle un peu à toutes les sauces
dans les tchats rap et d'ailleurs pour
moi le buzz c'est pas du tout le mind
russie invitationnal la preuve je n'ai
pas trouvé très bon c'est quand il a
battu ma muse dans un mathieu oui
ouais mais ils avaient fait le pas avant
ouais gros buzz récents pour moi ce
n'est pas la matinale c'est le truc
avants solides chaise oui oui oui
sur son lit chaise comment le truc le
buzz quand il a battu dans un match
énorme angulaire en sang et quelques
parties à après après il avait déjà pesé
avec le championnat du monde deux blitt
de rapides quand il avait fait un
troisième il ya plus d'un an mais moins
en france annoncé laurent frayssinet qui
m'en avait parlé il ya trois ans ou
quatre ans même il va lui dire lui fait
hier c'est le prochain monstrueux et il
n'y avait pas tant il est monstrueux
mais il avait bien plus tôt il avait
très très bien senti il avait aussi à
vif kenzy aussi cette année à 6 rouges
elle avait fait le buzz quand il avait
gagné à quelques parties il était bien
parti mais il arrive un bon tournoi
non mais il est fort il a fait le buzz
en avril quand il a fait nul contre un
certain mathieu c'est ouais ça c'est
plutôt mathieu c'est donc à fait le buzz
gt gt que pouces laquées noir marine et
blanc c'est un talent brut comme perso
j'en ai jamais vu parce que là j'ai vu
maxime très jeune mais c'est pas maxime
c'était plus le côté calculateur manger
jeu maxime pour la première fois c'est
un cas l'initiale reims en 2004 ça nous
rajeunit pas il avait 14 ans du coup
maxime moi je vais plus petit encore
mais parce qu'ils ont été jouées dans ma
catégorie donc j'ai joué encore plus
petit que toi mais wayne ou les tissus
reclasser de deux catégories il est aidé
quand même premiers lots avaient été
impressionnantes et rien n'en est
maintenu soit gelée connu je les jouais
il a vécu les 9 90 aussi les gens en
on y avait 17 ans et voit refuser le
truc c'est que comme il joue sur
internet on a accès à lui depuis qu'il a
12 ans en fait je tout le temps et
contre man u ça ait fait quoi que nul
pas mal ouais ouais ouais mais beaucoup
moins fort que maintenant mais il était
déjà de 1701 quelques c'est un bon
souvenir
ouais t'es déjà monstrueux ils avaient
fait nul à contrecarrer à calage 12 13
ans 13 ans n'était pas content que je
vais proposer la finale il me l'a dit
dix ans plus tard en islande en boîte
oui pourquoi tu va proposer nul c'était
très très grave
n'at il m'a dit j'avais parfois je me
dis je m'excuse sylvain shooter ouais
mais pourquoi tu es moins bien
maintenant mais la finale était nulle et
à qui il a tourné la tournée j'en ai
humain mais il était jeune il a refusé
tempo et j'ai fait nul après tu as le
droit non c'est inquiète tournoi qu'il
avait joué maintenant ça c'était un
super souvenir d'ailleurs ce jour là
pour moi c'est un très bon souvenir
c'était en coupe d'europe des clubs avec
le club de cannes pour lequel je vivais
à cannes à l'époque je travaillais pour
le club et c'était le premier match
officiel de monsieur hollande en tant
que champion du monde
il venait d'être champion du monde donc
coupe d'europe des clubs
il est est en turquie il détient et dans
le yacht du patron de grains que et il
est venu je donc c'était baden baden
contre cannes échecs et c'était son
premier match de reprise donc il rentre
dans la salle standing ovation première
partie il est champion du monde il vient
d'avoir le titre tout le monde m'aime
bien calme à nantes
il rentre donc c'était vraiment
impressionnant et prenant partie là les
blancs contre un certain mur tu as
casse-gueule eev qui fait nul très
facile vers passe aurait plutôt dû dire
à londres qui a réussi à annuler très
facilement contre mais mortes at-il été
bon à l'époque un qu'elle a quelques
couleurs pour allende on avait les
blancs purs passe tranquille tranquille
et dans le match le match était
surréaliste au 1 1 en 1h toys aux deux
robert fontaine nul contre eux d'une
heure aux trois cheveux nul contre
carson mais après on a perdu aux 4 5 6
on était un peu plus clément leur équipe
c'était genre bacrot nilsen il avait
encore un autre 26 francs un autre
monstre grosse équipe à weston espagnol
as je ne sais plus quel jour et c'était
une yourte hayef possibility cette année
son répertoire en ville c'est quoi ce
match à la coupe d'or des clubs c'est
fantastique s'était pas autant dans un
lambda
c'était un tournoi pour moi à hubert
importance apprend enfin je rencontrais
sert joaillier c'est super ça non mais
mur tu as à l'époque il avait un jeu
tellement actif dynamique il était
également rapide ça vaut 100 reprend 1
17h09
oui c'était un genre danon dans moins
fort en réalité un mur tu as dans le
style peut-être moi ça me fait penser
plus à mamediarov il adore avoir inclus
on passe était par exemple mais rtas
mais tellement heureux avec son passé
oui là d'un mea mamediarov aussi j'ai
posté à marquer il adore ça s'est fait
au top il a fait top 100 mondial a quand
même bien souvent on oublie on l'oubli
mais il était il était vraiment bon il
était sportif de l'année au kazakhstan
aussi mur tu as assez beau sportif de
l'année dans son pays c'est pas tout le
monde on se rend pas compte quand on est
un peu loin
ben vas-y tu as chez nous serait qu'il y
en ait ma paie correction ce seigneur tu
as enfin bon ça prouve qu'ils soient
aussi moins bon dans les autres sports
ça prouve qu'ils sont pas très bon et
d'un milieu pauvre ces dépenses étaient
à voir ou après le dopage
c'était avant c'était c'était avant
vinokourov mais a peut-être pendant mais
aussi en kazakhstan ils ont quelque
chose d'assez étrange c'est que en fait
il ya kazakhe kazakh pour y aller kazakh
ethniquement kazakh et non uniquement
casaque du coup ça peut aussi jouer mais
eux de dire une bêtise mais c'est pas au
kazakhstan qu'ils ont moins d'un
changement de capital récent away alma
ata comment s'appelle autres mais astana
et astana voilà mais ça c est à na waie
salmat est normalement même ou par non
ils ont ils ont chanson par chance je
crois c'est plus tard a annoncé un gros
piège c'est nous
nos soldats qui ont changé encore une
fois mais c'est génial c'est le nom de
l'ancien président il quitte je m'en
vais comme un prince la capitale c'est
mon allée non mais c'est un petit peu un
peu spéciale abba mirtahsmab un petit
peu raconté maintenance olten c'est
fantastique
mais d'ailleurs ça c'est un truc les
gars vous pouvez ce piège là dans une
soirée enfin un petit pari entre potes
je pense ça passe très jeunes ou
tranchant très bon et j'en suis tout
leur saoul tonnes annoncées
c'est un gros c'est un gros projet
l'élection de la fidh mais va le mec le
nouveau président qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas c'est pas un gens dont c'est
l'ancien de barre à droite poutine ne
faut pas trop le critiquer sur internet
mathew tait a peur non mais je sais pas
si les gens se rend compte à quel point
le mec il est illégal gong après c'est
que toi tu te connais beaucoup mieux
parce que moi j'ai déjà parlé plusieurs
fois nouveau président de la fide mais
c'est pas non plus un gros c'est pas un
jambon non moi j'ai déjà vu à plusieurs
reprises dans des soirées mondaines
moscovite eu envie de te dire
donc je connais même viennent déjà vu
son frère tu vois mais il m'avait l'air
sympathique le peu que j'ai eu après je
ne connais pas du tout c'est pas s'il
est bon ou pas d'ailleurs même nom mais
après il fallait faire quelque chose
parce qu'il y avait un problème avec
l'ancien président comme non plus
empathique
pratiquement une sympathique il est sain
90% des gens ne connaissent pas cette
année après tu peux leur donner un
concédant une équipe avec le cyclisme
quand même ça fait astana dont vous
suivent le vélo on n'est pas non plus et
astana tu sais ce que ça veut dire bas
et je pense qu'on a déjà dit mais j'ai
oublié combien capitale maintenant je
sais qu alma mater c'est il ya des
pommes là bas parce qu'il ya aussi une
une sorte de pommes qui s'appelle comme
ça ma mémoire
waouh quelque chose dans le style ça ne
nous mentait skywest à la dure mais non
oui de voir qu'au budget markovic qui a
aussi c'est lui qui était l'organisateur
pour la russie de la coupe du monde de
football quand même pardon g7 voir kovic
qui supervisait la coupe du monde de
football je sais plus exactement son
mais oui c'est vrai c'est pour ça que
celui là il y avait un point de timing
annoncé sa wii mais donc versé comme
quelqu'un de sérieux on est bien
d'accord mais on est bien d'accord
non c'est pas l'élection à la fidh en
fait cdc les fédérations fait chaque
fédération un vote un poids non je ne
sais pas comment c'est souvent le nombre
de licenciés que je me semble non je
crois par un bot 1
du coup ça va changer ça n'a pas changé
avec ma journée mais bien parce que du
coup les meetings utilise offre plein de
trucs qui font ce qu il t'a des cadeaux
quand il ya des années des élections
c'est sympa bien sûr un tiers de ses
besoins
ils ont leurs stands et tous sympas
c'est ça ouais sympa quoi
alors les parties ça a recommencé dans
trois minutes
autant dire bientôt mathieu way petit
bémol sortant non un peu trop d'attentes
entre les parties ouais il ya beaucoup
de temps d'attentes de base c'était une
demi heure et puis après ils ont ils ont
rajouté du temps j'ai trouvé c'est un
petit peu dommage de personnages trouvé
que passer 30 minutes 38 ça paraissait
bien 45 ça me paraît un peu les tu
prêches convaincu mais je sais pas un
c'est un plus c'est un changement qui a
été décidée après la première la
première journée en fait c'était prévu
pour être une demi heure ils ont rajouté
du temps enfin pas tout à fait comme ça
c'est juste qu'il voulait avoir une
heure fixe de début de la seconde ronde
et comme la première fois ils ont
commencé avec dix minutes de retard et
que les parties ont duré c'est un gros
bémol est classé mais déjà une demi
heure ça me paraissait beaucoup mais je
les ai bon ça permet de refaire les
équipes pourquoi 45 minutes il ya
vraiment un quart d'heure de trop de
pause ils ont arrondi c'était le premier
jour il ya une partie qui s'était pas
fini à 45 ça c'était de base ou en fait
c'était prévu pour finir à 15 et
reprendra 45 elle avait fini à 24,25
donc ils ont dit oui bon fra 17 heures
tous les jours
mais honnêtement voilà c'est prêt à une
réaction de champion
ouais c'était pas je trouve ce n'était
pas l'idée du siècle bon après y'a pas
non plus mort d'homme donc ça reprendre
maintenant dans deux minutes j'ai une
joueuse de l'équipe de france qu'on me
demande quel est mon site de belote
c'est même pas une bêtise attendu qu'on
a la compo est alors à gauche on a déjà
parlé un petit peu avant non mais c'est
loin on est favoris un mois mais c'est
pas c'est pas facile facile un fil rouge
il peut tout peut arriver
amined12 hommes duda j'adore il est mais
pour moi il est meilleur qu'à mine même
s'il très sympa un minime mais par
contre il est très dangereux ce est
menaçable après il est très près par
able c'est que le stand n c'est que
brière c'est que l'espagnol ya moyen de
faire mal dans l'ouverture
ouais après fil rouge aronian c'est
vraiment way aussi ces pays n'est pas
facile ce matin parce que ça doit qu'à
soi comme si elle connaissait être
connais bien ces schémas
si elle tombe dans un de ces chemins et
peut très bien battre nana enfin metz et
c'est pas un match
claire quoi radjabov dangereux non mais
pas dangereuse fin en compterait jarry
l'a éliminé il a éliminé dans des
rapides
non ils avaient éliminé en longues
pendant nice est un joueur de compte un
maître qu'attend et si tu viens me
chercher il va répondre présent
en plus il a peut-être un peu doit être
un peu revanchard consciemment ou
inconsciemment à mardi a été très très
chaude entre les deux d'accord
ouais je pense s'il est motivé contre
une personne c'est aujourd'hui oui nul
c'est le plus probable
abbas m il est innée médecin mais il
bosse pas beaucoup enfin moi j'ai un peu
quand je joue avec mon équipe on avait
partagé notre chambre ensemble ils
s'étaient pas de travail et pas vraiment
vraiment en train de mettre en place
[Musique]
angelov il a été numéro de monde autre
au mondial je pense qu'il est passé de
1800 ou 2700 je vais faire une
transition qui va pas être très belle le
temps de mettre en place je vais lancer
la part les jeux mais j'ouvre ait une
partie pour pour que les gens les à
l'écran et je vais finir la mise en
place de là
monde voilà la partie c'est maxime qui a
les blancs donc on va changer donc
décalé ce qui me rejoint l'estonienne
qui est la joie hier jaune on retourne
au second vide c'est pas maxime ne peut
on pas dire c'est pas les cheveux de
maxime sa danse et guéridons c'est pas
guéri guérison et la gambie dame
classique c'est ce que je joue tout le
temps à deux autres peu comme dakar
comme kane sms que maxime va arriver
avec une petite idée
henry joue le full deux assez
intéressant ça a été je l'autre jour
derrière l'idée c'est que prince etc at
on n'est pas obligé de reprendre tout de
suite de rock est d'abord tu penses que
la position et l'idée c'est chirac en
fait c'est comme si on fait fou des
trois pions procès qu'attend on sera
obligé de reprendre tout de suite mais
là on peut attendre un peu l'idée c'est
ici on peut jouer soit pion de france
aux dessins ses pions prend moins de
notre réponse
donc c'est petit avantage que de
nouveaux c'est un peu comme dans les
premières parties qu'on a vu c'est une
petite finale un peu mieux en théorie
way serré fou qui donne l'avantagé au
voir français mais ne trouve que le
fossé lui n'est pas très bien placé du
coup ils vont me venge le b 6
probablement pour le sortir du coup ça
peut créer des trous avec lagacé 6 par
exemple
ouais j'ai toujours pensé que c'était
pas grand chose q mais il est solide
rajab enfin il sera dur à battre dans
cette position à voir comment le jeu
manque elle prend une pose une question
je sais plus sa spécialité
ces épisodes le foot français 4 c'est
dur de trouver un autre coup non au
moins qui donc là deux écoles soit v6
wallace heath avec ou sans échanger
bonjour et p5 mais bon c'est mon affaire
b6 des six - appris et là aussi une
question de la tulliste verdun meuse
est-ce que c'est mieux de faire des
emprunts d un président et un émanant
des 6 face à ce genre de question que le
mec doit se poser peut-être que b si
c'est une faute juste puisque b6 damas
doa préfectoraux rêve d un tour à siens
encore une fois fait une comparaison de
pièces on est juste mais développer
c'est pas juste ta part tu dois pas
juste connaître avec les non pardon la
face à la sérénissime et là tu peux ne
pas rappeler c'est sa nuque
voilà c'est simple là j'imagine qu'ils
se préparent un peu mais pas non plus
comme comme aux candidates
13 31 ça paraît logique épaississe donc
j'ai pas à 4 à 5 et un plan food et 6
pour prendre la colonne avec l'idée pris
ce risque bessette tour d un homo en a
récupéré la colonne donc on prend le
contrôle d'une colonne ouverte
d'après elle le problème c'est qu'on
veut sans ces échanges est trop pièce on
tue vie selon la fin ouais tu y seras
prêt forçant l'adversaire il y aura plus
assez de blocage à faire des
travailleuses 5 à peu autour des 1 mais
tour des huit maintenant faire tourner
un ce que tu gardes quand même la
colonne les imaginent que nous pouvons
amener leur world tour montré du mépris
des droits les fuites je dirais 3e set
et après ça crame dit qu'il avait nié
beaucoup de partis comme ça use their
3,4 il monte son roi et il joue
tranquille mais bon ça donne quand même
plus proche de l'égalité et qu'autre
chose aux femmes c'est quand même une
petite pression pour pour maxime a dans
cette partie qui on rappelle un match
importantissime mathieu puisque l'équipe
européenne en cas de
deux victoires seraient qualifiés à coup
sûr et j'ai volontairement laissé chine
usa le score en haut pour que si jamais
ça bouge on est tout de suite
extrêmement long le score de l'autre
match mathieu un match que tu poses
combien de temps par jour à prendre des
lignes je poste 0 je ne prends pas de si
moore rajab affecte les pièces noires
joueur solide azéri un mathieu de
nationaliser en moi on m'a toujours dit
qu'on pouvait pas dire azerbaïdjanais
mais en fait il paraît qu'on peut
écraser riz en fait c'est plus un peuple
l'a peut-être on peut on peut aussi dire
des haricots mathieu maintenant aussi
autorisé mais pourtant je suis inquiet
des haricots on ne sait pas mathieu
s'est dit les deux mondial et 2ème et en
fait visiblement azéri ça sera un peuple
plus que vous habille toi mais bon c'est
plus facile à dire la sellette niveau
c'est ça on veut des icônes et juste je
me suis posé la question on se fait un
petit avis a wave un petit tour donc les
ola abs hyper intéressant alors chercher
je savais que je sache ce qui la joue
solo de jean est ce que tu te rappelles
j'entendais parler ou pas à temps
regarde ça te dit rien c'est mon match
contre contre etienne bacrot gg ça et
donc lui-même à pajot cette ligne mais
c'est ce que j'avais préparé par contre
décati 6 et palmer un coup ce qu'on
appelle la variante frankenstein dracula
c'est parfait mais oui je viens
d'apprendre quelque chose
non mais il ya un truc assez marrant
nombreux bien c'est assez piégeur plus
qu'il n'y paraît dans le province et un
croc
par exemple ici tu uses et auront huit
fois et si ce serait une erreur je prêt
juste 3 éléphants est en fait à plus de
plan actuellement non mais le rire est
normalement le qui ont des domaines
c'est pour montrer rapidement mature
mais dominé ch 4 kg 5 et attaquer moi
c'est avec le plan des trois donc c'est
pas exactement pas donc il ya 5 fu
dessin m'ont fait on voulait juste faire
un truc rapide à mathieu juste pour voir
je joue cavalier le 2 juin zina
et des cinqs des 5es à 3 y'a pas apte à
fouday si certains médias russes et 6
non mais c'est 6 ha oui j'ai pas b4 à la
casse et 4 donc ça va dans tu dois
prendre mes ados me parle reprenant jeu
simple je voulais mettre la dame
n'importe où en fait même nom soit là
dans les points
il a fait à 3 direct avant qu'avait lieu
de donc tolère france et 3b français 3
qui doublent et t5 qui va donner une
belle qu'asuka réunion c'est carole à
jamais les noirs c'est la pause mais
alors il ya eu à 3 mai à de jouer
bizarre mais france élite et encore des
trucs un peu un peu naïve mais
heureusement ceci j'ai tout bien
[Musique]
bon alors du coup on peut continuer
notre notre avis général avec duda qui
jouent contre le docteur à une espagne
en voir passer rapidement espagnol c'est
à dire que 126 change à mes amis nos
petits problèmes par on sait qu'on ne
pas aller le chercher sur sa breyer pas
ce que l'on appelle de maxime une année
en top 16 en top 12 est là salariale
avait pris l'eau après tout ce n'est pas
forcément non plus mathieu le joueur le
mieux préparé du après moi c'est ce que
j'ai déjà joué avec les bleus d'ailleurs
j'ai déjà perdu sur ce avec les blancs
bon ça se joue ouais moi tu vois je le
fous ces deux courbes et 4 je sais
jamais si tu dois prendre mon des quatre
essais mais en fait j'ai toujours pensé
que c'est mr x et blanc et après les
abords jouer je pense ça va poindre et
il va nous rester à
la dernière partie de nana et bien sûr
comme ça n'a pas ouvert dans les noms
des parties retrouver son pseudo ça va
être compliqué ça va être compliqué de
chez compliqué alors attendre essayer de
faire un tour de magie de dinars ça
marche aussi
c'est la même partie 1 donc on a joué ce
qui allait noir un analyseur est rien
bien sûr ce petit problème
maxime timeline sa transpose dans une
taille madoff alors attendre passer du
début des six aînés dinara est vraiment
dangereux dans les ouvertures en plein
time and as fap réussi un assist non
maintenance intel mais il faut trois
fautes et si c'est juste connu pour être
peu bon j'ai pas trouvé hier n'ont
qu'eux-mêmes avec ok même dame des deux
je vais faire tu auras des seins je vais
juste tête nue je vous prends et torrent
est en pointe seaska idée simple donc
sacrifice de qualité mais je comprends
c'est fin c'est juste c'est connu cinq
safran ouais c'est pas très beau mais en
relisant ces fous des 6,4 dam des deux
est le jouet rock pourra d un full méca
ont bien ri gary doit être en sueur en
face cette partie les cinq mêmes non non
f5 ses parts à des 5 tu contre les cons
le contrat devait remettre mon fou je te
fais foulée 4 d'abord pour éviter qu'il
y ait 5
mais là non ça ça va tu as raison mais
bon goût mais juste retour d un phobique
a pu en prendre 50 points 5 il ya des
points 4 août
il faut que tu défends tu fais trop dam
des trois dans le détroit peut-être pu
loger fleuve seront joints mais ça c'est
sûr que on va prendre un singe se fout
des quatre têtes et des six
et on peut refaire le truc en fait je
pense que les noirs d'affaires français
3 bon tu peux pas laisser un cavalier
dans ce type de police mme way et tu le
fais quand en fait ce que le champion
prend là t'as pas le temps à peut-être
surtout reprend non mais il faut le
faire avant alors ça dans le métro mais
du coup je peux pas vous dès 6 ans tu me
cette étude venge sur le 4 mai je suis
pas encore sacrifié peut-être des fois
çi stone
ça gagne tout de suite non officielle
d'alger 3 et je parle je suis à la main
sac
quel massacre cette partie qui pourrait
durer vraiment 15 cours est là je damned
qu'elle a faits qui ont pris les devants
la foudre un f4 ces salons mais son idée
m pas ok ce qui est peut-être mieux là
du fait des six principaux quand même le
faire mais après l'hôtel et garuda
veulent faire comme ces cinq pour
arracher un full aux 6 mais bon la mp4
beckham c'est ken block est simple un
peu loupé ça s'appelait attentats mais
bon on va revoir mathieu on peut rester
juste une seconde sur cette partie avant
de retourner puisque ça pourrait être un
terrain important
après moi je pense que j'ai les mains là
je réfléchi longtemps qu'elle g8 même
nom mais l'impulsion ça va juste pas
regarder le développement et regarder
cette caisse des cinq lait trop
importante
voilà c'est simple ils ont une deux
trois quatre cinq pièces développées
contre 2 et en plus le fou qui peut même
pas sortir au prochain coup et sur rock
on a une tactique qui gagne dante direct
puisque la même si on fait dame ces cinq
échecs 3h un damage six cavaliers
systemat instantanée et la seule pièce
qui est pas la bpca taurin mais qui est
en elle un coût et dans l'attaqué ouais
ouais enfin et la torah 8 s'il y aura
plus qu'un coup pour alors est ce que tu
peux je donne des six fils car il était
c'est quasi finir non mais franchement
je préfère qu'on change ce trop
déprimant sol un alors là tout l'été six
mois je pensais le mercure tu peux pas
ok c'est pas ok côté cimetière en avoir
c'est être trouvé après on fait le rêve
ici ça sera un bout comme tour d un je
vous fais un coup de fouet aux six
reprises pris ce prix je vous fais un
petit coup de pied 17 10 tour de magie
et ça je peux obtenir la finale avec un
cavalier mots simples et plus intuitifs
c'est moi même mais ça ne peut vraiment
la tenir compte dit n'a aucun doute non
merci événements ça va pas chez maxim
qui a rien obtenu et l'impression mouais
surtout content aussi pour moi le seul
plan je connaissais un peu dangereux
certes re 4 et il n'a pas fait donc gens
ne te dire ça va faire nul réfugie à
level en rognant c'est peut-être la
solution la plus intéressante ça de y
perdra pas je vois pas d'idées pour les
blancs sur les droits et sur le après si
une solution de signer il ya peut-être
une sorte de statu quo voilà c'est
peut-être plus égale qu'autre chose en
fait les deux camps peuvent pas faire
grand chose
enfin les deux cavaliers peuvent pas
beaucoup trop bouger les foules non plus
non ça c'est la prison la plus
intéressante en fait mais quand on y
réfléchit on n'est pas surpris non
mathieu leçon je pense vraiment que de
ce qu'on voit c'est quand même la
position de dinars à là où tout se joue
parce qu'on est d'accord ça ça assez
riches plutôt vers une nulle
c'est un beau sac d'audace et le seul
endroit où on veut gagner ouais mais je
pense qu'il est très important là
mathieu de voir la décision de
2 dinara les assez lente
elle est assez lente enfin là le truc
c'est que c'est vraiment si elle fait
tourner m6 qui a aidé 5
enfin on peut repousser la nuit des
talents parce qu'on n'a pas on a dit b4
était bon mais en fait on n'a pas
expliqué d'ailleurs j'ai juste eu comme
moi même pas sûr à 100% pourquoi c'est
le meilleur c'est juste pour mettre la
dame sur une très mauvaise cassin un
plan de relance c'est 6
qu'est-ce qu'on n'a pas trop envie
prises maintenant tour f-16 et menaces
qui les cinq doubles échecs
elles attendent de passer sur 7 donc
c'est pour ça qu'on joue bekkat
intermédiaire pour déloger cette dame
c'est simple peut pas rester sur la 5e
un tout les cas sont trouvés donc c'est
une forme assez fort c'est en réalité
convient de regarder les amis si dinara
trouve ça en fait ouais mais pour moi ce
n'est pas anodin pour moi c'est la bosse
on a besoin d'entendre monsieur m&a oui
et non parce que si elle fait tourner un
et qu'on commence à faire faut aussi
sous poids ça veut dire que là on est on
est plus perdu sa fait-on quand même si
c'est quasi finie finir par ailleurs
cinq minutes et le fermage suis pas sûr
qu'elles le fassent du coup est ce que
ça vaut le coup d'aller voir le match de
la chine cette position stratégique m'en
aller elle est hallucinante
donc c'est christophe schanne sur tout
avec un avec les blancs dans cette
partie là mathieu il ya eu ces six
mètres de là deux écoles cavalière 4
pour donner ses cavaliers ou deux ou
alors prise m6 prise l6 karen f4 pour un
essai qui aurait lieu de il s'en prendre
aux pions
c'est hyper riches par l'opposition
moi je pense j'aurais pu retenir trouve
du jeu genre un truc fou 5 f 5,6 passes
c'est possible
qu'ai je prends un avion + 1 prise
fourrage 3 ça marche ou pas crise un peu
en bluff prise idem du sein d'un match
cas
le 5 mai la f4 je calcule d'après
mexique sur un rush de toute façon qui
on peut faire d'amen 4s et un statu quo
j'ai bien pour les noirs il ya même
trois nefs de en fait et sur royal 4
aussi d'ailleurs
non ces morts là c'est dangereux dans
deux mois sa citadine un peu au pif mais
du coup c'est pour ça que je prendrai un
f6 monde pour stabiliser un peu plus la
pause et dames mauro bien donc là tous
les ans comprend un choix alors on va
montrer un genre si on fait tourner leur
fourrage 3 faire ça m ennuie avec la
dame en uf6 ce fut un choix vraiment une
idée donc il faudrait de hockey des deux
mais d'amener un petit plus logique là
dès maintenant elle a plus rien à faire
là bas mais j'ai du mal à croire qu'on
soit mieux on n'est pas moins bien c'est
légal du coup peut-être et alors ça a
joué du côté de dinard à aller suspens
ont été châtiés et elle n'a pas fait
donc ses cinq échecs d'ailleurs au
passage je m'étais niro h sans obliger
du coup c'est malin le roi et plus loin
pour la finale mais elle s'est dit oh
non je mène à eux mêmes auront enfin
pour la finale ok baladé ce que gagner
un pion j'ai envie de dire c'est un
moindre mal d'avoir quelqu'un de moins
de 6 7 5
on va troquer value ouais ça bon c'est
évidemment n'est pas content on a un
pion de moins mais c'est pas forcément
gagnant pour les blancs et en chinois
sont en train de perdre d'accord nickel
tu peux juste avait peut-être toi ton
côté nous faire un petit point auquel
sanaa sans forcément à partir surtout
les échiquiers sinon on s'en sort plus
c'est au rythme annoncé
carrier qui n'est déjà fait nul c'est
quoi la masse que je dois regarder je
trouve pas a dit mme ding
il a essayé de réfuter l'italienne de
naka mais on a vu que c'est dur et nk
l'ia ses poils deuxième échiquier le
deuxième serait ça doit être soleil de
caruana nakamura caruana au saut à jouer
une berlin ce très solide ça devrait
faire un nul donc un prétoire dominguez
caruana je vois pas qu à l aller
planquer je ne trouve pas de couler donc
car on a sorti une prépa sur la petrov
on passe de monter on n'est pas très
contents ou là c'est un massacre
enfin lors de karwan à wemmel lui à kehl
les fous prend un chef qui marche est
donc là regardez le master class de
libye à tanger la m puisque ça peut
peut-être julie bon c'est juste qu'elle
est fou j'ai kate était catastrophique 1
de bongo buddy l'aurait donc il ne reste
qu'une alors soit joué and june soit un
seuil ou qui jouent et alors déjà la
jeune ouverture quête d'auteur elle est
mal mais ça reste un mal compliqué mais
oui elle est rien donc ça veut dire
qu'elle à sochaux tempo au moins
ouais ça veut dire que ça veut dire
mathieu qui va falloir gagner ce match
et je peux te dire que je sais pas où on
le gagne parce que on est mal partout il
va vraiment falloir un exploit alors que
le plusieurs semblaient être fait en
battant
les états unis aux matches précédents on
est remis dans le mal
mathieu je reprends ton écran bon ok ça
nul
ok puis - nul non mais police fighter
peut gagner peut-être comment il a
trouvé policiers il réfléchit encore
réfléchir encore est donc prise d'amd 1
à 5
je pense qu'on est pas mieux mais bon on
a trop hâte en a trop on peut parier
prise prise ah si on peut au point d'un
point fut pas un trois-pièces décade ça
dans quel monde tu gagnes dont combat je
fumais qu'avaient les u17 être un peu
mieux on tenait tant à 8 bat laura temps
il vient de jouer mathieu vient jouer
qu'à relief 4 merci aux normands sont un
peu plus son style en moi je disais que
j'avais peur de fouet aux cinq tonneaux
et f5
peut-être que j'ai dit une bêtise mais
ça ça me faisait ta façon il a dû bien
calculé pour entrer là dedans il a dû
calculer bien c'est qu'elle a dû
calculer quelque chose
john kapon un film l'oeil parce que
c'est le jour et john kapon je pense a
alors tout le 5 franchement j'adore ce
coût va être pour expliquer après quatre
ans puis on prend ça me remet la
structure et ça nous permet de jouer à 5
encore plus facilement de la sas
apparaît encore plus fort de moins
jeunes après il faut 5 est pas un
coussin plein mais juste un pareil pari
fort c'est hyper logique ans la
benjamine joseph 5 en fait si tu fais
rien je remets de madame ans et de mon
cavalier en e2 je vais arriver amoureux
groupe est il comme la pollution assez
fermé les deux cavaliers peut être assez
fort à l'écart et les sons et pièce
courte portée qui sont souvent plus fort
que les fous alors c'est chaud c'est
chaud mathieu c'est chaud pour pour les
européennes dans cette position va dire
qu'elle est équilibrée a les bonnes les
vannes après c'est pas nul nul hein ça
peut jouer ou non
mais peut-être moins bien richard paraît
que c'est ça passe à passer je pense que
c'est légal parce que veulent faire les
blancs en fait j'ai 5
il croit pas trop à chaque j'y crois pas
trop 1,5 j'y crois pas trop
pour moi c'est le rendement et j'étais
gamin et et nana est ce que ça s'arrange
un peu à la fête tous ces huit wallon
après spa change pas le maître dans cet
art aide à vous les empêchez caïds et 5
sauf qu'elle est 17
elles attaquent ces deux pas des mines
juge aurel fait qu'à et 17 km d'abord
pour empêcher au 5 mai peut-être que 5
qui est décèdé on peut dire son club les
eaux je la comprends faudra peut-être
pas fait mais je comprends parce que
caruana vient d'ouvrir le score 1 contre
eux en garde donc la position
[Musique]
ouais c'est très bête pour les chinois
les américains surtout en plus si les
gagne aujourd'hui vous enjouer saveiro
battre demain ils sont champions
ouais je pense que les américains sont
peut-être plus embêtant que nous et on
n'est pas maître louis fanny second
chien est quand même plus forte un ouais
alors de quel côté tu veux on peut
retrouver un peu sur maxime après maxime
peut-être que c'est encore inconnue mais
moins que les blancs j'aimerais bien
faire f34 joli coup de fouet f2
cavalcade pour forcer des 5 et après et
en moins comme ça je comprends la case
des cinq sens je pense que je suis mieux
car il est un casse
mathieu qui ont essayé de bloquer le
foot et 7 avec la chaîne fait ça c'est
très instructif
les furets retrouve à kaboul on peut
dire ouais ça paraît bizarre de mettre
des pions sur canne blanche qui elle
flambé cette non en fait je le fais
taper sur un mur il n'y a pas de rupture
ma chaîne de pions commençons g2 il va
pas jouer h 5 h 14 3 ici ouais ouais non
c'est sûr mais we find ways serait pas
mal en 5 ou contre après on gère pas les
autres équipes c'est aussi à nous de
gagner j'ai reçu un truc ni la 10e 4
direct
1 ok j'ai pas vu que c'était possible de
jouer un peu après si tu étais beaucoup
d'âmes en fait on n'a pas vu non mais
c'est logique de commencer par tv3 tu
t'ouvres la colonie nous n'avons plus
peu plus haut 4 1
bah si tu protèges station avec la
carène et je fais le 4.4 et prend 4
tours france est un qui avait pensé que
j'avais pas vu juste pour montrer je
parle mettons ça mais ça gagne où il est
peut-être encore un paul il ya un peu
des sports ça passera peut-être ce
sauvetage par une victoire de maxime
mathieu dans cette position moi je
dirais plutôt une victoire de du dude
même nationaux mais mais il faut gagner
le match la nature mais qui perd voilà
non aux copains ce que ne dit aucun mail
si l'équation est maintenant simple on
doit gagner ce match après si on n'est
pas capable de dominer la plus faible
équipe du tournant mais avec pas d'être
en finale non plus et c'est paco c'est
pas faux je me fais trop les donc donc
donc mathieu on peut retourner un peu
sur trois fous 17
c'est bien ça sur le long terme je pense
que les blancs sont le traitement
j'aimais pas la position donc toi pas
très bonnes intuitions d'aminé lieu de
et en plus la dame en b3 regarde elle va
avoir une autre utilité mathieu c'est
comment tu fais c'est 5 on pourra
éventuellement aller taper le pion
bessette
enfin deux variants donc dam des trois
non seulement qui sort du vis-à-vis fou
dame mais qui au passage en plus
mais un deuxième but a misé sur le pion
17 il sort tout sachant qu'on avait peur
de l'idea cap 5
maintenant il y aura des ces cinq échecs
aussi oui la dame est vraiment bien
placé et un jour elle peut aussi reculer
en v2 et sans prendre option des 4 mai
jeu j'essaie de lire le chat je fais pas
tout le temps que ça ne fait pas un peu
ouais je commence à aucune idée tu vas
faire à trois caves l2 regrouper ta
position est bonne si tu fais c'est
simple même si t'arrives pas à gagner
bessette défaut tu peux juste repartir
avec un gars il ya un dessin ça me jean
yves dupeux ici et de jouer pour être 4
aussi genre qu'avait lieu 2 kg trois
calèches de f4 monter une attaque
tranquillement sur la droite et demi un
structure
je pense qu'il est un peu mieux il est
le plus dur est passé donc maintenant ça
joue maintenant dans une position de
travail
mathieu que n'a pas coté nana
gens te dire à ces prêts aux sangles
j'aurais vraiment les impôts qu'on va
s'en pire ça s'empire ok pour un 5e set
ajoute un bum - ouais je fus un truc tu
peux bloquer c'est une majorité claire
maintenant et ses quatre tentatives tout
cas et c'est quoi tarifs 6 et j'avais
pas vu mes tours et même je sais c'est
qu'elle chante pour 17
c'est plus chic leers à sa maman au
moins c'est le bordel qu'est 2006
cherche aux platines
car il y prend tout reprend raté ma
place à la légère - des 8,3 ses sept
taureaux 8 peut-être trop jeu ouais
c'est mennana tu vois un contre joué jun
aussi l effet une partie comme ça après
qu'elle ait passé j'ai l'impression
qu'elle connaît rien dans les ouvertures
et fait pas d'efforts avec les blondes
la trouve tellement plus fort qu'avec 15
ans ouais on a aujourd'hui la dans un
match si important c'est quand même
dommage c'était un choix qu'est-ce qui
part en place sainte anne à musique zouk
c'est plutôt la titulaire normalement
d'ailleurs alain mais kasparov qu'elle
s'ajuste se passer de ses services
ouais je joue moins bien qu'avant un
assaut demain alors on va retourner chez
maxime vachier lagrave notre joueur
français on a vraiment besoin du
français il a joué cinq ça ne
m'intéresse pas structurellement ça
m'intéresse la case des cinq événements
si on joue à quatre f3 en plus on
pourrait avoir un ou amnesty et le club
peut y arriver nain il a fait foi h4
maxime je comprend aucun alors attends
fois jeu 4/6 si le carrier bouche du
coup tu prends rêve 6 et tu feras qui a
été sympa le cavalier bush s'était pas
son projet d'aller en belgique non non
mais
j'aime bien flash 4 1 - je comprends pas
juste tu joues qua non mais je dis juste
que je comprends bonne idée je peux à
chis m'a fait à fils
genève 3
je suis comme maintenant je fais moi le
marin
pour ce 7e 4 tours s'est vite four
moquette et j'ai une autre question
est-ce qu'à cinq unités pour la fhcc
comme toi mais à 5
[Musique]
est ce que tu veux jouer là dessus
moi je sais pas ça marche je sais pas
honnêtement je suis parce que vos faux
h4 mais bon il a joué il a joué juste je
comprends pas l'idée - c'est le courant
lui-même qui arrange pas j'ai rien
contre un fonds hbp je ne comprends pas
ni démon 60 des écoutes mathieu f34 en
fait on fait quoi être qu'a t on à la
casse des cats après pour les cheveux et
f-35 c'est ça qu'il faudrait trois à
cinq
scipion foulée 5 pts à prendre soin ces
deux obligé ça j'aime pas ça ne donne
pas trop inquiet des cinq léché qui
celle qui a donc revient peut-être que
tu peux jouer fou b5 sera simple f 3 à 5
fu b57 écoles atuge et 5,1 à la foule
non attends il eu des coups mathelier
fou prend f6 qui est progressiste
cavaliers à 4 il serait très très
concret on va le bessin qui va jusqu'à y
c'est simple ouais il veut dire que
calais 17 tu peux pas ouais quand tu vas
jeu qui a aidé simple mais je te ferai
1.4 et tu vas devoir bouger dans tous
les cas se plomber ses comptes mais je
n'aurais jamais fait ça mais aurait
peut-être que ça marche qu'on nous fait
remarquer qu' à un cavalier nouvelle non
mais c'est non mais c'est un bon en fait
à toutes les parties lanmérin sur le
camp
c'est marrant ouais c'est relatif enfin
petit tour allait enfin un petit tour
police fighter moi j'aime bien la petite
position qu'on voulait le petit plus et
ils jouent très bien je joue à 4 ici
d'ailleurs j'aime bien 4 ce que tu veux
jouer à 5 g quand le mec te fais à 5 8
fév et 5 tu commences à ça j'aime bien
je ferai un quatre mains ok donc on va
dire que polish fighter écoutons à la
position qu'on voulait les bons c'est un
les bons ces choses là toujours le gain
mensuel sans peut pas lui enlever
mais il envoie du lourd quand même notre
ami sir ou djadja note tommy iranien non
je cherchais le nom des habitants de
chars chartrain sorte notre ami
chartrain bon d'accord c'est un peu
dangereux qui est morte à fouquereuil
votre fard à chaque doigt comme lille ou
à paris c'est space mountain côté à
dinara puisque tout reprend g7 n'a pas
été jouer mathieu a prêté sa carrière 8
tours b 4 et alors là à donato temps
elle a eu peur des gros bien allez
perdre au kenya su ce que je sais c'est
pas tout réussi ce moment-là enfin la
loupe et bien avec les dessins physique
mais je réponds toujours pas d'ailleurs
à cavaillon 3 quel est maintenant ça se
loupe
ouais mais du coup c'est très content
d'être entré dans saab
si tu de jeu ça n'a jamais été aussi
merveilleux et maintenant moyenne c'est
ce que j'allais dire tour quelque part
n'importe des miracles bon ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle côté côté on appelle ça
une embellie
ben ça c'est une embellie elle a joué
cailly c4 écoute c'est incroyable de
plus avoir de pions moment dans cette
partie parce qu'on partait de très très
loin tour d3 et d5 on
villa mathieu côté européen j'irai
peut-être à 4 quand un peu moins bien
mais elle la perdra pas un peu de
psychologie que la maj doivent être
dégoûtés de voir prendre seront
pyongyang
maxime cavalli avec la tour prends c'est
un tour français a été joué et
maintenant food inc
mais moi j'aurai jamais chez soi jusqu'à
saint gingolph 3e 4e f 2 pour répondre à
quelqu'un dans le chat dans la partie de
duda je pense que tu peux prendre 2 à
enlever cinq pour répondre à xen et gars
est ce qu'à faire car élite des deux ici
mana illa pas le choix non c'est dur de
trouver un objet les 5 6 et 5 bouffe
c'est ça avec vous ces cinq études ou le
petit ma bouffe pourquoi bouffe
pourquoi pas de tours s'est vite
spontanément participation même tarif et
peut-être même les noirs savent a fait
un nul ça à faire nul mais des trucs ou
cias est le plus intéressant parce que
fait notre maxime qui se prend la tête
radjabov j'ai bien sale affaire nimsoft
carlin qui finance estime me suis mariée
au deuxième temps son niveau il 9 s'est
mis sur 8 aux deux c'est quand même
énorme
il est plutôt réussi ce qui a valu à eux
deux pour montrer pour coter siro jamais
assez cavalière 4 elle a tout regardé
devrait plus de cases sur la colonne
j'aime pas ça l'opposante
moi je conseille sur g5 il devait y
avoir un peu mieux que simple dans la
case de 3 mais ça sent que je vais avoir
un problème donc maintenant les deux
nouveaux modes sur un nishiki on dirait
plus que si tu fais pas tour sur la
colonne a fait tourner et hi5 m'étais
mal là ça veut juste dire tellement bien
il me giauque ya eu 2 kiev que tu as
loupé ça c'est pas mal vu au moins
éliminé un défenseur des cases avec
quelques attaques sont quasi blanche
aurait dû maintenant gala cazaux 5 pour
le fou en cavalier prend que l'on prend
si les blacks en même temps fou de
saint-quentin très très minces genre
qu'avait lieu 2 qui avait quatre c'est
comme ça ça ne nous aiment pas
des réseaux de martiens bras noirs qui
peut se retrouver sous pression en cas
de nul des européens vis je connais pas
le départage les américains partagent
maxime qui a fait foot est un nom mais
stratégiquement c'est catastrophique
soit parti si ils seront dangereux
surtout qu'ils sont fous des deux
dernières parties la leaf housse la
merde
ouais je vais pour les cavaliers non
mais les deux géants nakamura c'était
génial
maxime maxime qui n'a pas l'air en super
forme aujourd'hui un nom mais elle
prendre le train c'est que c'est le
meilleur équipement tu peux pas le
sortir
non mais il est quand même il fait il
fait quand même le taf mieux mieux que
que ce qu'on aurait pu mettre à sa place
mais
j'aimerais bien kiffé ce nombre montre
que c'est nul serait content maintenant
a fait un petit tour
hadja peuvent qui peut faire mal dinara
elle a bien joué à quatre elle s'est
reprise quand même 5 je peux par ok
qu'est ce que je fais c'est ce qu'elle
vient de jouer tu menaces rien mais tu
empêches le roc accueille à temps réduit
cette échelle à 5
tu peux pas prendre 1 4 enfin tu peux
mais tes pattes ayman taha 4 qui a et b
un site hors cas d'échec qu'on parle
problématique 1 pour les noirs cette
tour qui rendent pas un jeu vas-y à
simple c'est peut-être bête 18.4
s'affiche juste un mois du coup quitte à
le perdre au coup d'après mais elle voit
c'est que tu fais quoi tu peux pas ok on
est dans le dur un lien du fc valence -
cavaliers 5 et 6 1 ça c'est une idée
toro 3,6 aussi nul me l'instant pensée
de tête
si tu en prends un carton ce point senti
menacé même pas parce qu'il y avait le
tampon ouais je refais là là on n'a
jamais été aussi bien well as tu
souffles la mafia le voyais égalité
matérielle ça y est c'est vers ça
fatigue
c'est possible on est moins bien partout
c'est senna faire noda est encore un but
avec hérité 5 ton truc là il était pas
si mal puisque avait lieu 5 m6 piqué le
5 juin pour des deux
même pas un n'a pas tort si si si tu
veux pas casser sa tête à chaque achat
toraille 4,02 tu peux pas jouer avec six
mois que faire tous réussissent j'ai pas
vu car ils élèvent 14 fait un tarif pas
mais bon c'est mieux que tout à l'heure
mais c'est sur le thème ça peut se tenir
encore quelques indique n'a quand même
moins bien maintenant va jeter un oeil
ok ça j'espère toujours nul mais il va
il est moins bien pour moi maintenant je
fais pas une grande partie aujourd'hui
seeding peu peut gagner contre nac à sa
sage car je manque encore un peu de
culture dans ce type de structure
il souffre un peu dans ce type de
structure encore il faut qu'il y va
passer par là mais ça va être un peu dur
au début mais il va progresser avec sa
saab à la fin il sera mien je jouais jun
ont réalisé un bon alors les vols les
vannes de viande à garder foin a été
malin ouais mais tous rachète manon ça
me paraît moins claire
c'est vrai il faut que les bonnes nous
sorte une grosse défense parce qu'il est
gamin sous pression mais avec les noirs
ici j'ai mal je sais pas s'il est
vraiment mal mais il est sous pression
au rachis ça gagne pas tout de suite je
crois qu'il guérisse est mature prise
moi je s'applique pas de bonnes cases à
saissac et la qualité
t'as pas de foot et 3 passes quelques
arrivées deux protège les médecins ouais
la chine et la chine donc du coup et il
se passe quoi à l'échiquier à
l'échiquier qualité chinois elle a fait
tour 3 c'est l'embellie de nouveau coté
à côtés d'anna donc nakamura un pion -
mais et tunnels très difficile non il a
une finale difficile nagas mais c'est
pas sûr que ça attend veille à tour
bessette et pénible aussi en interne aux
20,4 tomber sept
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle a joué à dinard
à l âge de 17 attend des buts qui
essaient set ça ouais autour des 8 c g
et c'est ça se passe ici à part boire
fisc a valu six échecs mémoire des sages
et j'avais du temps car il est prompt à
6 et une chaleur monte wayne on met ça
mais c'est l'embellie temps n'a jamais
été aussi bien de la partie je vais
après avoir un pion mais enfin joué john
était vraiment mal
elle a fait tour des huit nana mais tu
menaces rock la wii ne se logique tour
de vis d'ailleurs ce même plus logique
que ce que j'ai annoncé s'être laissé
passer ça mais tu vas l'asrock c'est
reçues ferco prochain tu souffert a
gagné en vain coup matt soar échiquier
et que rohan ses cinq adversaires dont
naka souffre caruana donc à gagner
elle est plus moins bien et wayne john
contre crush et ssolh dernier saut
qu'est-ce que celle signée eu des gros
coups rouge familier mais là le danger
vient de tête du joueur français a aussi
dans ce match mathieu la position
maximas empire il faut des 3 4 des 5
crise mais le premier actionnaire à 100
de toujours faire nul c'est plutôt à de
nouvelles caisses est simple puisqu'il
vous prend qu'un point b 4 on va pas
vraiment la persona 3 il fuit plutôt
dire que beckett snow chaque fois qu'a
tenus je peux faire un faux appel dans
tous les cas il n ya quatre ans elle fit
mal fou aux deux têtes c'est humain les
pussycat et pour ça je crois au rev 2 je
vais m'en sortir
ouais ça devrait passer donc maxime
peut-être qu'elle c5 qui s'en sort
les ventes sur dur qui va commencer à
menacer qui avait promis ville 6 aura 5
à chaque fois il veut je b5 et reprendre
une pièce plus d'un pion c'est
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être plus malin
que à 4 que ce que j'ai proposé tout au
long si j'avais une position comme ça le
pata gagnant gagne des casses tu gagnes
des sudistes hugues ghenne bessette qui
n'ont bien évidemment perdu à laférois
f7 alors attention mais c'est pas bête
du tout réaliste a remarqué qu'elle
inclut le père mais jean retour 17 segal
je sais pas jouer roger 6 je pense mais
moi j'ai six tours j'ai 3 technip a vu
huy watch is to reprend j'ai cet échec
autour des deux d'abord je vois ouais
donc tu fais tu fais plutôt tour 17
non mais là elle a fait rage et six en
fait c'est pour ça que je comprends bien
peut-être 3,5 alors je te fais le tour d
un tour de huit salles times gagné bon
alors dit va dire que oui mais non mais
c'est très très chaud ok on comprend
l'idée de nana mais nana là qu'ils sont
nés vraiment cette fois ci je pense
qu'elle on est vraiment sorti du moment
difficile tout peut arriver mais la
pendule à l'autre je pensais qu'elle
avait été plus longue que ça l'a quand
même pas si mal son temps d'initier mais
l'objectif mance avait invoqué polish
fighter dont on vient de le voir
donc il est mieux ok donc maintenant il
ya des diablos réellement l'otan bonne
nouvelle mais radjabov web écailles c5
jouer radjabov maxime qui va faire nul
qui devrait faire virtuellement bien
mais c'est mieux que de talent donc on
est de nouveau vivant on est de nouveau
vivant et les van leeuwen non c'est
damon qui faisait par les veines ses
onze milieu compte trois études non
pourquoi il est manquent pas cavalier
c'est ton avis ouais
peut-être qu'à la fin tu me fais ton
pouce et un elfe ou des troncs dans quel
s est forgé 6g des quelques 300 euros 6
triste triste soutient qu'elle c4 que
les trois axes à saïda bien comment ça
il a vu six rouges a ouais mais ça ça
peut faire mieux
bizarrement tu donnes laquelle tu as tes
potes bon moyen de donner à gaillac je
n'ai pas pensé à ça 3 4 ça peut se tenir
dans notre que c'est quand même angle on
va revenir c'est le principal a déjà
parti s'était il n'a pas fait cavalier
recettes et tour g7 à fouet suspens la
tourache cette non c'est pas si con
ailleurs fait preuve auquel ariane liste
donc maxima vient de viande vient de
signer là nul donc écoute boutoir de
maxime quand même un afflux une victoire
aux premières études heureusement qu
radjabov pas trop d'ambition je
t'annonce contre 1,40 à nanning caruana
sera encore angel intime
oui alors ça c'est une bonne chose de
faite
notre apathie hyper important qui gagne
ça n'arrivait vraiment très bien les
bons mâles et à nice et à temps il ya eu
quoi lierrois j'ai six salles a fait
cavalier c5 d'inattendu attendait d'eux
quéau 6l venir faire du cardio 6 c'est
quand même bizarre d'affaires tour 17 au
coude à louvres way attend autour des
deux carrés lieu six tours pour ses huit
buts dont g3 wave 5 kg s'être quatre
tours fait quatre tours c4 mais c'est ça
la lire un conte et contentons g4 pour
la france je rentrerai jamais là dedans
wade s'en est vite rentré à la sarre a
pas un symbole dingle
jamais tu que tu fais tu me fais jamais
joué ça avec thé noir et si tu fais tour
d un échec pour le 2e tour des huit je
ferais plutôt ça ça sent mauvais - non
mais je pense qu'on fait ça tous les
trois ça passe quand le prince et que
c'est impossible a loupé puisque c'est
le seul coup ouais mais ok c'est
peut-être le plus hype ça caille et
trois jeux qui est qualifié samedi d' on
comprend qu'on prend tour à champ ça
doit aller ça prend tout rachat ça va un
peu moins bien mais bon elle a été
tellement moins bien avant un plus un ça
ça ne ferait pas peur donc leeuwen
dès qu'un prénom nom avec caméra ça va
aller c'est à dire qu'on va mettre
maintenant les fans sauf que la semaine
on se bat seul alors attends ça change
en fait les gamins changement arrive on
va mettre en valeur dinara c'est bien
contre elle n'a pas une reconversion
encadreurs non nana est très très mal
cadré donc on va mettre les joueurs
non non pourim échange ils meurent
change la caméra rien non c'est par mca
c'est notre ami c'est notre job en sorte
qu'il a change pas sam à aller coûte
maintenant je pense plus qu'il a change
non normes il a rechargé dire de plus
changer ses tickets ci fais ça c'est ça
c'est pas moi voilà attends je vais
écrire mais non mais ils rechange c'est
simple si j'allais dire il te troll non
il est très serré c'est à gizeh zag ni
yande c'est pas c'est pas du tout un
troll sam c'est pas c'est pas le genre
de la maison
c'est pas moins il dit pas mais c'est ça
c'est ça
il a dit c'est pas moins et c'est sa
missa du coup il connaît pas son prénom
tout n'est pas sombre et dont tout le
monde le troll c'est samedi 3 mais on a
dinard à elle a joué huit heures il n'y
avait pas pensé mais c'est logique pour
contrôler la case au 6ème et tours j'ai
trois mâts qui me faisait peur bref
quand même à gagner aménager cinq tour
de l'ain a est maintenant égale et
maintenant on va gagner
dinara elle vient de du kazakhstan c'est
une fois j'ai fait dire des gîtes du
kazakhstan mais je voulais pas fait une
très bonne cuite à leur nom je suis pas
un super fan produits tabesh autres
c'est sympa non non mais j'ai décidé il
a décidé de me troll
non mon idée dit qu'ils ne s'étaient pas
lui faisait pas exprès et sam
c'est ça qui tranche en écoute on aura
les deux caméras on va
on va enlever le nom ça changera caméra
et j'ai un bep médina dinars sur la
carte désolé enfants le gros sur la
chaîne l'équipe s'est pas diffuser mais
sur l'equipe.fr tu vas dans direct ça y
est alors à tanger vonn qui est juste
complètement foutue via cavalia il a
réussi à se regrouper de fou c'est un
fou des 3c lapierre confier c'est
complètement gagné en cavale et h5 ça
s'est fini donc ça va faire 1 0 aux
niches fighter c'est fini
un partout pas du tout c'est le milieu
de jeu il reste toutes les pièces mais
c'est vraiment la position de nanas qui
est importante
du coup on va gagner 2 une attente bruni
va vérifier ce qui se passe de l'autre
côté là parce que c'est important de
partout dinara qui a quatre minutes à
l'ouest les souhaits gagnant à cause du
dernier coup c'était également le désir
ding ding pression mais j'ai besoin
vraiment de bonnes chances de nuls
maintenant alpes après il faut qu'on
gagne le match on n'a plus aucune chance
wang hao c'est fini et crush crush ça va
mais va perdre donc on fait
non en fait il faudrait que wang hall 1
allée perdu il faudrait que new là sauf
contre sow et c'est pas gagné tour g3
jouer alors que mathieu on fait notre
record d'audience actuellement je tiens
le rhône et 6300 ça va bien se passer
c'est pas mal donc merci à vous de
suivre cette équipe l'ancien galeriste
partie mais ça va ça passe par là pour
nous on n'a plus le choix maintenant
non c'est possible que les américains
fassent nul c'est le co qui m'embêtait
ça les change tout et donc du coup mais
du coup on va se faire éliminer à la fin
c'est moi ou pas non non je les
américaines toi de faire nul ou encore
harry peuvent faire du bruit donc nous
faut qu'on fasse il à tout prix et à
saillon ravira de l'autre côté j'ai
apprécié mon père mérite pas d' aïda
temps n'a cassé peut-être cadre d'un
là deux points de moins dans la finale
non mais c'est le bordel de partout là
mathieu je pense à yu hwan john est
mieux quand crunch je pense qu'on doit
rester nous du côté de duda en fait
parce que de l'autre comme j'essayais
gagne pas c'est fini tu veux dire un way
et puis de l'autre côté
ces vêtements on va garder les joueuses
à la caméra pour le moment on va
regarder tout il va nous faire un
massage on sait qu'il est très bon blitz
ouais ça va ce parent histoire de tout
ça les mecs ça passe c'est condition
sinequanone d'un match prenait assez les
blancs sont beaucoup mais tombé six
tours c5
on va améliorer la position petit à
petit il ya du drame à la mathieu la
tour le pion c6 qui est menacée côté
noir le docteur amine bassem en sueur
face face au joueur polonais toute
l'europe ou face au reste du monde
mathieu et qu'est ce qui se passe
surtout 17 du coup ici n'ont rien on
domine toronto rgt b737 700 ramener un
cahier sur ses gammes et les kabyles
sont pas malades s'ils attaquent des
cats il mobilise pas mal de choses
autour un jeune bien ses choix un v6
menace manas le pion le pion ses 6 et 6
donc ouais vraiment eu dix tours à un
tour à sept jours et la septième rangée
dans le chatt ya quelqu'un qui dit un
truc sur le site de l'équipe vous allez
dans direct en haut il ya une grande
bande avec échec
donc c'est plus simple vous allez dans
direct et vous avez et vous avez une
grande bande échec vous cliquez dessus
et vous allez me voir
non d'ailleurs de super coq a validé
deux très bien joué ouais pas mal ils
veulent un ses 5 ans et 4
il se donne le choix et je vais
peut-être pas même pas les ans à 5 j'ai
l'impression pour aller en ville et pas
pensé mais oui tu passes par ck oui donc
une minute trente pour amin immigrantes
pour amin et la position est compliqué
non mais mon le jour égyptien en plus
ian fry ça fait quand même plus fort
intrinsèquement kamin bassem mais il a
la pression quand même peut-être d'une
qualification en finale de cette
compétition
visiblement le lien marche plus
aujourd'hui dommage tout se joue à tous
aujourd'hui mathieu à envahir à rognan
et à dire c'est fini on va regarder une
dernière fois mais ces abandons hockey
voit bien là je vois plus rien et cette
position
ça va faire annuler
et c'est même les noms les blancs papa
unis donc ok ben ouais tu as raison il
faut absolument que pouliche fighter
lagane et après faut voir ce qui se
passe que tu as américains parce qu'on a
le score au dessus et c'est toujours les
américains qui mènent qui mène 1-0 on
voit on voit les d'après d'après donc le
petit module 1 c'est pas un module de
ouf
nu hoang est peut-être s'en sortir
maintenant et jingbo moideen gagné
emphatique médina qu'on nous dit 10
gagneur je vais quand même en allez
allez jeter un oeil
parce que là ça part de partout les amis
ding pour moi c'est gagnant mais j'y
vois la poste explique pourquoi tu me le
rende b6 ouais d'accord je fais c'est si
tu mets ton cul en c6 et qui après qui
pousse tant pis et tu fais fou d'éviter
hk pour protéger d'autres états qui ont
la beauté sa bombe selon h
mais peut-être que les noirs ont le
temps de va les découvrir dans ces cas
là je peux langer set et je vais je
viens de tout soupçon alors les voyait
tous un téléphone qui a les bonnes qui a
perdu à je te propose un petit couteau
il ya un gros plan sur sur
jean-christophe je te propose qu'on
suive
maintenant peut-être un peu la partie de
jean-christophe sur laquelle tout va
la schl estime jing père et croches un
an ça y est sauve à gagner au nom
hollywood journal a pris nul ah là là
c'est la catastrophe
elle était mieux dans la position de
mieux au temps il va nous éliminer en
fait pas mieux la position de me ottan
nul et il y aura in young jin
si aujourd'hui perd 6,6 et permanent
vraiment éperdus et ding ding à cette
vague et ils vont perdre deux matches
chez nous il nous faut qu'on vient une
de match nul c'est sûr que c'est mort
moi je dis un miracle de nana on va on
va vérifier un proco la virage mais pour
avoir suivi la compétition après y'a un
truc de perte de machin mais je suis sûr
que ça va pas suffire
c'est pas l'un contre l'autre
confrontation directe non non complot
des chinois et des américains
on va là ça fait nul de toute façon il
faut absolument tout à égalise lemmy
autant son avantage il est moindre en
qu'avant mais à lattes avec un second
normalement c'est à dire du bien à moins
qu'ils aient du faux h61 bonnement
faudra vérifier un le départage que ça
peut changer avec les pertes comme je
disais d'une rive à l'autre il faudra
aller voir f4 la main peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il faut acheter du coup
peut-être une erreur parce que
maintenant après puis on prend 1,4 et
prend et desquels elle si ce dont on
avait joué au con d'avoir seulement
wilaya psion des quatre situées en l'air
mal à être tranquille et frontaux rassaa
couvrir et aura sa à couvrir wen au
fronton t'oblige de tours aussi déjà qui
est un des quatre filles du coup on va
te fait un match nul du coin fr mathus à
jour départager faudra les tchèques et
les règles exactes par les youyous qui
perd avec les blancs sont une berlinoise
off ça arrive elle even qui est bonne
partie de furiani qu'un impressionnant
ce petit appareil va faire tout
reprendre quatre noms
il va tout risquer je comprends et
détroit j'imagine tutorat 8,8 des prend
2 à tort à 8 sa soupe prises on relève
deux tandems donc les taureaux ont
d'abord mais ça il va le voir très vite
c'est sûr qu'ils le voient tous ravis
soudas il a quel âge c'est une bonne
question pas mais c'est fou la chine a
lâché qui perd les usa quand même nom
mais surtout mai dernier un radjabov
quand il a peur quand il a prétendu
fendre tendu non prendre quand il a dit
avoir travaillé pendant deux mois il n'a
pas cité rajab or son équipe c'était
dominguez kariya keane il y avait un
troisième nom là il a trouvé 3 à 8 ans
je verrai ton france et huit français
pourrait d'ailleurs source et 7 c'est
peut-être précis à trop forcer la tour
romane auspices du ressac
ouais j'aime bien tord c'est cet ouvrage
et 8,3 un fouet f 4 tours 2 on est
tranquille voyez un problème c'est aussi
de l'équipe visiblement il faut prendre
un autre bien plus armée pour deux
projets de froid comment tu défends
demain tu peux pas dans ton rêve 2 mais
oui tu gagnes plus du couffo dévoilé
vise en premier mais précis jusqu'au
bout jusqu'au vous avez 10 718 jusqu'à
présent c'est leur seule défaite
ouais bon à prendre
au prochain mathieu tour des 1 voilà
donc ça ça va gagner un pas de doute les
youyous le souci c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment culte chez cuit 1 il n'a qu'à
jo toujours mais je suis ok pour moi ça
perdant qui vont perdre deux ennemis
voulaient va gagner parce que quelqu'un
à la calculette
t'as pas le classement en arrivant le
départage
mais en fait le départage qui peuvent
changer ils ont un départage bizarre à
la performance car comment on va voir je
dirai après mais normalement on est
derrière on a mis moins de points et on
a on n'a jamais fait de massac avec
l'europe et on s'est fait massacrer cry
où il a défendu une et bien c'est bien
moi j'en ai dit qu'il était mis en
position difficile brest ses qualités
plus net ça va gagner ou à l es le roi
non à un peu faible autour des 1
toujours bien de changer tant qu'homme
pourquoi ces biens échangés tout parce
que du coup notre roi peut monter plus
facilement d'entre eux sont alors f3
maintenant ça mais ce qui est dommage
c'est qu'on va les états unis deux fois
c'est vrai par les a battus au match
aller les plus machos des trois fuites
sur f8 3e 5,3 f3c lombez lien voilà en
fait je pense y a pas de coups qui
perdent par une gaffe 10 de mon point de
la puce demi point de plus de départage
pour les américains et demi mais je
croyais la presqu'île en deux mois et
demi c'est possible ou non ça doit être
un point on va on verra les
confrontations directes compte on va
voir si les lions vont du jeune derek
compte on saura exactement je vais te
dire façon faut gagner cette partie et
je vais te dire le départage ménaka
c'est sur ce qu'est ce qu'il a je vais
te dire non au su de quoi
mc axa gagne pas a dit qu'il a gagné pas
si je crois que ça vienne soit c'est
lors du game boy game mais bon j'aurais
fait dans l'autre sens c'était plus
simple
départage je suis pas sûr que ça vienne
maintenant attends je vais je vais aller
demander je crois que non pour moi ça
gagne si tu fais roi c'est sympa des six
neal a gagné ne veut pas non non ça joue
encore moi je suis en train de demander
le tie-break exact parce qu'ils disent
que dans certains classements on va voir
on va voir dans tout axer sur qui va la
gagner il faut j'ai cinq amis tu
regardes pas la russie je regarde un
regard j'ai la partie sous les chats je
regarde la faune tu peux la mettre pour
lui préfère attendre sonne enfin je veux
dire j'ai la partie du joueur européen
on passerait s'ils gagnent pas si kiev
ne pas blesser après s'arrête diop a
gagné fera guère flottant ouais c'est
fou que la chinoise accepte tenu l'un en
étant mieux autant le sang puis ça fait
par l'équipe c'est sûr
ouais ça passe bien mais si on perd pour
un demi point important de partir de
maximus et font une mauvaise journée
c'est l'hiver 15 euros sauf un ils
auraient dû faire un retour de karachi
suspense l'abandon on l'annoncé d'audace
étaient un trait dans une très bonne
idée de mettre ses chics et blancs
c'est une machine bing gagner mais bon
j'attends toujours qu'on me réponde pour
savoir si c'est le 6 et le départage
particulier du coup c'est un départage
particuliers ou pas diana qui dans le
chat est en anglais ils disent que cette
victoire c'est les américains puissent
qualifie nikkei finit la partie de
dynacom aura fini bah pour moi en fait
je truc départage particulier je n'ai
pas
je n'ai pas lu les gestionnaires de
chasseneuil ce que juste c'est pas le
site organisateur tout simplement et que
je fais pas du tout confiance au
départage surface casals je préfère à
temps mais non là je comprends de ce
trésor que c'est juste pas le bon rythme
il se trouve que il se trouve que moi en
fait j'ai le truc de départage
particulier je n'ai pas lu j'ai lu que
c'était à la performance après il peut y
avoir un alinéa que j'ai raté un ça
arrive à tout le monde mais a donc c'est
pour ça que j'attends une confirmation
officielle annonce mais voilà là là là
il ya bien un team usa bien ce que j et
il me rock troisième dans le chat on met
des fake news bien ce que je disais
départage ça va pas enfin en tout cas
c'est le truc officielle à alger devant
les yeux ouais mais ya pas eu d partage
on ne sait pas de combien pour moi même
et normalement il le met bien
à moins que le que le gars qui fait le
qu'il fasse le standing se plante
normalement c'est ça oui mais je me
doute bien mauvaise nouvelle le scénario
terrible
ok ils m'écrivent que team usa a été
édifiée à ils me disent désolés mais
voilà c'est juste ils m'ont mis la
pression en mettant la fox news dont le
chat noir fait que news corp a faim j'y
peux rien les gens qui mettent des fêtes
news mais oui c'était bien c'est bien ce
que j'avais sélectionné deux fois et
éliminer l'un s'était partagé la perf va
aller gagner ce match après il était à
notre portée on rate on raque le match
contre le reste du monde on peut s'en
vouloir qu'à nous mêmes un show que wade
dans le match et à quoi a dit plus on
est chanceux parce qu'à un moment on
glisse le polish il était pas si bien
dans l'ouverture non allaités au bois de
boulogne
ouais on a raté on est passé à travers
le match maxime tu fais pas une grosse
partie on a une sim qui est moins bien
avec les blancs vote nul
on s'en sort très bientôt rognon a
égalisé dans l'ouverture mais après il
s'est fait dominer
oui demi point c'est vrai même pas la
personne 0,5 ret arrive enfin oui oui
c'est ça c'est vrai si maxime guasch
trois équipes à un point presse a fait
un point et on est qualifié comme quoi
ça se joue sur des détails en ces
compétitions après honnêtement les
américains ils ont vraiment une équipe
qui peut embêter la chine peut-être plus
que nous derrière on te voit après c'est
décevant on se voyait qualifié mathieu
oui bien sûr après on a vite compris un
camp dans le match et en tournée qui
s'est mal passé déjà c'est un demi heure
afin ak qui perd c'est quand même hyper
donc quand on a vu qu'à draguignan dit
coup on n'y croyait plus trop un nom
mais c'est yuuwaa john ne pas jouer là
c'est vraiment c'est comme ça mathieu on
va pas refaire l'histoire 1 c'est comme
ça les américains sont qualifiés je
pense qu'il faut leur dire bravo quand
même pour jouer par à prison ferme il a
porté l'équipe
heureusement pas une belle compétition
voilà on est passé à travers certains
matches on a eu un peu de réussite aussi
à certains moments on n'a pas vraiment
su conclure
au moment où il le fallait et on finit
ont fini troisièmes c'est vrai que ça
peut nous laisser un goût amer dans la
bouche mathieu parce qu'on on était à
cette équipe
arrêtez avec comme tu peux les états
unis à l'avant-dernière t'attendais
centre et les mains toujours les
derniers pas le droit d'y croire qu'on
mérite pas du tout d'y annuler c'est un
miracle donc limite le plus regrets ça
serait de ne pas avoir gagné plus cher
le match d'avancé 15 me
on aurait pu leur mettre cher en fait
bah ouais haut niveau la physionomie du
match et après la chine
est ce qu'elle a vraiment jeu de jeu
ouais je pense que oui quel but
même ses rivaux ifan ouais après ils ont
tourné contre nous aussi on fait jouer
jouer jouer d'un gouvernement ont fait
pas l'histoire lui non non mais je
comprends bien c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça une aventure qui se termine
pour nous après je termine ça se termine
ouais à m officiellement il ya une
raison qu'on soit vraiment d'europe pour
l'europe ou c'est juste puisque maxime
c'est moi qui ai décidé en fait c'est
une question absolument
enfin tuer mais n'importe quelle équipe
dont un français de d'enchaîner q
pourquoi je vois quoi je serais pour une
autre équipe
et si dans le reste du monde il avait
arrêté pour reste du monde aussi bien
fait
tu as un français ça te ça tenait au
dessus maintenant il ya un dieu de moi
le truc qui me dérangeait pas qu'elle
ait joué c'est qu'elle n'ait pas joué un
peu saoul final ça fait part de l'équipe
c'est sûr on va on va pas on refera pas
l'histoire c'est non non mais c'est pas
maintenant je sais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'elle est très forte et
normalement avec m meilleur que proches
juste mal qu'une partie ouais mais a
progressé de son niveau habituel
on ne dit pas une vaine l'avenue une
victoire très décevant n'en ad'ailleurs
au 1 c'est pas mal fini à plus 1 il a
quand même
hikaru nakamura en face nepomniachi
anand radjabov et dingli rennes
c'est pas en arrivant chez april a
manqué un peu d'énergie aujourd'hui ça
se voyait mais dans l'ensemble c'était
pas mal il nous avait quoi et sauver le
demi point contre un homme aussi été
fait pour moi c'était positif après il
enchaîne ça fait quand même deux mois
bon après le seul regret dans la
position de maxime c'est peut-être là je
croise aujourd'hui du coup s'il devait y
avoir un regret ses positions connues
mais il est dans qu'il a dit qui
jouaient pour nul c'est la la la
stratégie d'équipé parce qu'ils aient
sentais confiant de gagner contre du
moment pas de ça oui en fait je voulais
faire nul et bat le reste du monde et à
peut-être qu'ils ont eu un relâchement
battant les etats-unis en disant ils
vont perdre contre les usa ils n'ont pas
été focus et ses essais lebron qui nous
coûte le match final le joueur
providentiel pour pendant la compétition
ouais c'est ça c'est juste triste pour
lui il me semble mais des gens ratent
lundi hier aussi un en vrai en fait on a
fait nul contre l'un des nude coiffure
estreux du monde là dans les mains ou
payer les manières enfin massimi doit
perdirent et on se sauve de justesse
contre des attaques du monde avec deux
nuls un peu miraculeuse en fait on a
bien joué contre les grosses équipes
mais à mes concurrents dès le reste du
monde là le premier match on doit le
père on a été très poussive contre les
équipes plus faibles
bah c'est surtout que les autres ont été
peut-être plus fort contre les équipes
en étant bouchées bouscarrat labbadia
peine si grosse différence mais c'est
vrai que moi j'étais surpris de voir
l'un d'eux si bas par exemple cinq
points sur 20
ouais mais ils ont ils ont ils ont des
gens un peu de show car ils ont raté
bannu déjà été champions une défaite une
eu lorsqu'il va faire deux victoires tu
leur ajoute déjà trois points et ils ont
ils ont un peu de chose ou un ailier
n'diaye des lieux avec la menthe ajoute
soit parti après ils sont qualifiés ils
sont assurés d'être premier ils n'ont
pas le choix on demande tu prends
l'europe est là mais bon ils sont dit
que le rap allegri contre le reste du
monde saturé
c'est un match qui compte pour du beurre
on peut pas du tout reprocher ça a lâché
2 fhp fo non non c'est nous c'est nous
nous perdons dans tous les cas ça fera
une belle finale demain ce soir c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça c'est la vie
on s'est ratés on a raté le dernier
match c'est comme ça c'est une
désillusion non plus la compo pour moi
était bonne dans les matchs eepad non
non tout a été passé juste au sahel
non mais c'est notre façon c'est la
fadette c'est quand tu gagnes pas tu
mérite pas de gagner afin de qualifier
ces deux points de départager j'ai
vérifié
je viens d'avoir la foi et aussi de 1000
points ça peut donner des regrets oui ça
peut donner de gros regret même du coup
de toute façon et demain on commentera
quand même avec fable du coup la finale
usa chine et la semaine prochaine nature
on commentera avec toi le championnat de
france
now blitz donc on va commenter pas mal
de choses blitz en partenariat avec la
ffeu passé les otages sont vivants ouais
c'est ça son taschen perso ouais
exactement comme ça que l'on ya le lien
juste en dessous si vous voulez
bitstream ce sera la semaine prochaine
donc on se retrouvera fois que ces
samedi 14h si vous n'en fait plus et 14h
ou 15h mévente façon durable à la fois
vous avez les milliards joueurs français
tournoi premier jour tout le monde est
qualificatif et il y aura un système
coupe avec les premiers le lendemain si
je te pète bethune exactement avec je
crois que ça débute en huitièmes de
finale
alors là c'est ça donc c'est se
qualifier et c'est un joueur qui sera
bientôt ouvert à tous les tous les
joueurs qui ont une licence ff française
et le flou même les étrangers pourront
pas gagner le tfc étrangers peuvent
gagner toi mais pas le titre pour faire
simple on éliminer web pour un demi
point départage
comme quoi ce n'est pas que un truc
français tu as les européens aussi garde
garde la tradition française comme quoi
la preuve c'est qu'il y avait 1
française il avait le chat noir
pourtant j'ai eu mon sweat préféré on
nous tarde de lui porter bonheur
c'est fou la gueule est dommage dans mon
monde l'a bien vibrer avec la victoire
du super premier match hyper chaud non
ça on peut menacer un peu parce
l'enlever on a bien vivre et et ben
écoute du coup on se retrouve
il ya encore une partie en cours en fait
tu connais rougail est jeté un oeil pas
très intéressantes à dire il ya aussi et
pour moi c'est sûr côté très très très
bien préparé mais pas indifférente
sapers j'aurais mis de carillon g3 et
pousser les pions mais roanne en bref si
ce fou ou bien
non mais ça c'est pas mal ça ait changé
les deux pions on le fout de vous perdre
le quart à londres ça frémit juste taxi
tuque à toutes tes pièces c'est encore
nulle cette info bon c'est pas la
position la plus passionnante mais il y
a qu'à le score dans ce match
du coup je sais ça j'ai pas le temps de
me le donner
il ya toute façon les russes ont déjà
gagné le match en plus maniaques il a
été facile j'ai vu carla qui n'a fini le
rapide l'autre handwriting d'oublier
quand tu es g5 un g6 tgca 3 je vais pas
g6 g51j 4-5 pardon et j 6 ou ramener
leur voile tu mets le cas en gros un f6
avec lequel est un art catherine aussi
assez facilement non j ai juste pas de
piège sur la pollution et assez
inintéressante genre kg 4 noyer ventre